hello and welcome to our Channel if you
are fascinated by the world of coding
and eager to dive into python you have
come to the right place today we are
going to explore some exciting and
beginner friendly python projects that
will not only boost your coding skills
but also spark your creativity whether
you are a complete newb or have doubled
a bit in programming these projects are
perfect for getting your feed wet in the
Python Programming World our goal is to
make python approachable and fun for
everyone by the end of this video you
will have a bunch of cool projects to
show off and a solid understanding of
basic python Concepts so grab your
computer open up the python editor and
let's get started and if you haven't
already don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe for more awesome
programming content and just a quick
info for you if you want to upscale
yourself master artificial intelligence
and machine learning skills and Python
programming language skills and land
your dream job or grow in your career
then you must explore simply learns
cohort of various Ai and ml programs
with Python language simply learn offers
various certification and postgraduate
programs in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
waron Purdue Caltech it kpur and many
more through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt
engineer ing explainable AI machine
learning algorithms and over a dozen
others and that's not all you also get
the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from industry experts
working in Top Tire product companies
and academicians from top universities
after completing these courses thousands
of Learners have transitioned into an AI
or ml role as a fresher or moved onto a
higher paying job and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin command and
description box below to find an AI nml
program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest a project on Python
and how python can be used to invoke and
send messages in WhatsApp so what we're
going to today do is we're going to
demonstrate you how to use pyat kit it's
a python utility which is available in
order for you to interact directly with
the
P Python and WhatsApp so we will show
you certain examples using which you can
directly interface with your WhatsApp
now in order to perform this activity
first you need to go to your python
installation folder now in my case I
have my python installed in my app data
local programs python python 310 so your
first task is to go and open open a
command prompt from this
folder and then you need to install pip
install PW kit so under python 310 there
is a folder scripts and you paste this
command and you should get this
particular message if you have already
installed pyot kit if not then python
will install the relevant library in
your computer
after you have done this then go back to
your python root folder go to the python
terminal and then run the command import
pyot
kit okay so after you have installed the
pyot kit library then you need to import
the pyot kit and this message should be
successfully imported now I want to send
a WhatsApp message to a phone
number and I want to send it at a
particular time so right now I'll just
set the time as
2038 and please make sure that you are
already logged in to your
web.whatsapp.com
and so that you know uh the when python
tries to send a message you are already
pre- logged in okay
okay so now if you see with this message
with this API I'm going to send the
message at 839 so this will go and open
the WhatsApp window in next 46 seconds
and after 20 seconds the message will be
delivered so 8:39 so when the timer in
my system clock will reach to this
particular
time python will open a whatspp WhatsApp
window log that reach to this phone
number which is there in my WhatsApp
contacts and then after 20 seconds this
message will be delivered so let's just
wait for a few seconds and wait for
python to perform that
activity yes now python has opened the
web.whatsapp.com in which I'm already
logged in it has reached out to that
number and type the message welcome to
Simply learn world and I can send this
message now let's move on to the another
example if I want to send a message to a
WhatsApp group then you need a WhatsApp
group chat ID and the message you want
to send so now in order to send a
message to the WhatsApp group you can
pick any
WhatsApp group in which you are
administrator go to the group
info
and click invite to group via a link and
in this link
copy copy this part copy link go to
notepad just copy this part this is the
group
ID okay and paste it over
here
okay so now you
can send message to a group copy paste
this in your command prompt set the
timing in 16 seconds WhatsApp will open
a window and after 30 seconds the
message will be
delivered okay so WhatsApp window is
open it will reach out to that
particular
group
it will type the
message and submit it and even it will
close the window automatically now okay
so this
particular command has typed the message
submitted it and Clos the
window
now if you want to send the WhatsApp
message instantly you
just use the API send whats message
instantly and it will send it instantly
to the
user now another utility is that if you
want
to find a
keyword on
YouTube
so we'll just play on YouTube Simply
learn on YouTube
so it will automatically play the
YouTube channel which you have put in
that particular keyword on the YouTube
so python can also directly open a
YouTube url or if you want to do a
Google
Search Here It Go
so as soon as you put that command on
the python console it will open
google.com and search it in this video
we are going to perform a really
interesting data analysis using python
on the Spotify music streaming service
platform data set I'll also be asking
you a few questions related to Spotify
during our discussion please make sure
to answer them in the comment section of
the video so now let's get started
Spotify is a stest audio streaming and
media services provider founded in April
2006 it is the world's largest music
streaming service provider and has over
381 million monthly active users which
also includes 172 million paid
subscribers the total number of
downloads on the Spotify app in the
Android store exceeded 1 billion in May
2021 so millions of people listen to
music all day even I hooked to music as
an analyst what's better than exploring
and quantifying data about music and
drawing valuable insights before I move
ahead I have a quiz question for you
people the name Spotify comes from a
combination of two words so which are
those two words please let us know your
thoughts in the comment section below I
would like to repeat the question again
the name Spotify comes from a
combination of two words so what are
those two words we would love to hear
from you so please put your answers in
the comment section
below now let's use Python libraries and
functions to analyze and visual ual our
data set first I'll show you the two
data sets that we'll be
using so here is the first data set that
we'll be using for our demo and then I
have my second data set called Spotify
features which is essentially about the
geners of the different
soundtracks now these data sets have
been downloaded from kel.com now the
Links to the data sets have been
provided in the description box box
please go ahead and download them now
let me just go ahead and brief you about
the columns that are present in our
first data set which is about tracks we
have our column A which is ID this is
the unique ID for each of the songs then
we have the name column which is
essentially the name of the song then we
have a column for popularity so the
popularity ranges from 0 to 100 then we
have duration in millisecond this is the
duration of the track in milliseconds
next we have a column called explicit
now we are not bothered about this
column because we are not going to use
it in our
analysis then we have artist so the name
of the artist who has composed or sung
the song then we have ID of the artist
then we have a column for release date
which is basically the date on which the
song was released then we have a column
for danceability so this describes how
suitable a track is for dancing based on
a combination of musical elements such
as Tempo Rhythm stability beat strength
and overall regularity the value ranges
between 0 and
1 next we have a column for energy so
the energy is a measure between 0.0 to
1.0 and represents a perceptual measure
of intensity and activity typically the
energetic tracks feel fast loud and
noisy higher the value the more
energetic is the song then we have a
column for key so key is the pitch notes
or scale of song that forms the basis of
a song there are 12 Keys ranging from 0
to
11 moving ahead we have loudness so the
overall loudness of the track in decb it
ranges from- 60 to 0
DB then we have mode so songs can be
classified as major and minor 1.0
represents major or one represents major
and zero represents
minor a column for the
costic so a confidence measure of 0 to 1
of whether the track is acostic or not
so 1.0 represents high confidence the
track is acostic then we have other
information
about
instrumental then we also have a column
for livess so liveness detects the
presence of an audience in the recording
then we have a column for Valance so
Valance is a 22 onwards so all the songs
from 1922 till
2021 cool okay so I'm on my jupyter
notebook
so you can see I have a few cells that
have already been filled up so we'll
start with our analysis first of all
let's go ahead and import the necessary
Library so I'm importing in numpy pandas
matplot lib and cbon for my analysis and
visualization I'll hit shift enter to
import the libraries all right and in
the next cell I'm going to load my data
set using the pandas read CSV function I
have my location already put here let me
show you the location where the data
files or the data sets are located so
this is my location under Chrome
downloads I have a folder called Spotify
data sets Okay so let's import
and check the first five rows in the
data set so for that I have used the
head function there you go so here you
can see I have my first five rows of
information from the data set and on the
top you can see the different columns
you have ID name
popularity artist then we have the
release date danceability energy key
loudness liveliness or
liveness balance Tempo and other
information
cool now let's check for null values in
the data set I'll just give a comment as
null
values every time when you download a
data set from an open repository there
are chances that the data set would
contain null values so it's better to
check them beforehand
so I'm going to use the isol function
present in the pandas Library PD I'm
using because I had imported pandas as
PD so PD do is null then I'm going to
use the variable name dfdore tracks
because I imported my data set and
stored it in the variable dfdore TRS so
I have my data frame under dfdore TRS
variable and then I'll use the the sum
function to check the total number of
null values present in the data set for
each of the columns if I run it there
you
go so here you can see my name column
has
71 missing values or null values and we
don't have any null values for the rest
of the
columns
okay now let's use the info method that
will give us the total number of rows
and columns in the data set and we'll
also check the data types and the memory
usage so I'll say my data frame name
that is DF
tracks.
info if I run it you can see here now if
you mark there are total
58661 names or the names of the songs
present in the data set while the rest
all have 5 l
866727 song names or soundtracks missing
from our data
set and Below you can see the data types
we have float integer and object and
then you can see the memory
usage
cool now before I move ahead with our
next analysis I have another question
for you which artist or musician has the
most number of followers on Spotify I
repeat which artist or musician has the
most number of followers on Spotify
please put your answer in the comment
section below we would be happy to hear
from
you now let's move ahead and do our
first major analysis in this demo we are
going to find the 10 least popular songs
present in the Spotify data set so I'll
create a variable called sorted _ DF
that will be equal to my data frame name
that is dfdore tracks dot I'm going to
use the
sortore values function and
say my column name is
popularity so I'm going to sort the
values based on the popularity and then
say ascending equal to
True since I want only the least popular
songs and then I'm going to say head of
10 which means I want the top 10 least
popular songs now let's go ahead and
print sorted DL if I run it you can see
we have the list
of 10 least popular songs on Spotify you
can see that popularity is
zero and you can see the names of the
songs some of them
are songs which are not not an English
language and you can see the artist
names as well
cool now moving
ahead let's see some descriptive
statistics for the numerical variables
that are present in our column so I'll
say DF TRS do
describe which is the function to get
some descriptive statistics and I'm
going to use the transpose function
after that
if I run it there you go so we have the
statistics about count mean standard
deviation minimum value 25th percentile
50th percentile 75th percentile and the
maximum value for these columns like
popularity duration in milliseconds then
we have energy key loudness
mode cool now if you see this popularity
column the minimum value is zero and the
max maximum value is 100 and you can see
the 50th percentile is 27 which is
essentially the median you have the
standard deviation as
18.37%
90 so we are going to check for the top
10 songs with popularity greater than 90
let me show you how to do it so in this
cell I'm going to create a new variable
called most
popular and I'll say
dfdore tracks dot this time I'm going to
use the query function that is part of
pandas Library again I'll use the column
that is popularity and we'll set the
condition popularity should be greater
than 90 I'll give a comma and
say in place equal to false because I
don't want to change my original data
frame and then I'll say sort
underscore
values and I'm going to sort it based
on
popularity
in descending order so I'll
say ascending equal to
false and then
let's take only
the top 10 popular songs so I'll say
most popular use square brackets use
square brackets and we'll then pass the
slicing operator and say colon 10 now if
I run this there you go
so here you can see the 10 most popular
songs that is present in our Spotify
data set the first we have fees by
Dustin
Bieber Daniel Cesar and gon then we also
have a song name called driver's license
astronaut in the ocean save your tears
you also have the business streets and
heartbreak anniversary so these are the
most popular songs that are present in
our data set based on their popularity
you can see paches has the highest
popularity
with 100 all right now moving to the
next cell so here we are going to set
the index to be release date column in
the main data frame so I'm setting my
index using the setor index function I
have passed in my column name as release
date and I'm saying in place equal to
true which means I want to change it in
my original data frame and then I'm
changing the value to date time format
and let's print the head of the data set
so you can see here we have successfully
changed our index now here you can see
instead of 0 1 2 3 we have the release
date column and the rest of the columns
are
intact
cool now let's move ahead so suppose you
want to check the artist at the 18th Row
in our data set you can use the index
location method for that let me show you
how
to filter only specific rows of
information from the data set I'll use
my data frame dfdore tracks and using
double square brackets I'll
say my column name which is
artist and I'll use the index location
method and say let's say I want to check
the artist to is
present in the 18th Row in my data set
so I'll use iock 18 if I run it the
artist name is Victor
voucher
cool now let's move ahead we are going
to convert the duration in milliseconds
to just seconds
so if you see our data set we have a
column called duration in milliseconds
so all our songs are present in
milliseconds let's convert them into
just seconds so for that I'm using the
Lambda function and dividing the values
in milliseconds by thousand so that they
get converted into just seconds I have
used in place equal to true so I want to
change it in my original data frame
let's run it and do the necessary
changes all right now we'll print the
head of the data set just to check the
duration column so I'll say
dfdore
tracks do
duration. head if I run it there you go
so you can see the values have now been
changed to just
seconds
cool I have the final quiz question for
you who has the most monthly listeners
on Spotify please put your answers in
the comment section below we' be glad to
hear from you
now coming to the next
cell so here we are going to create a
first visualization that is going to be
a correlation map we are going to drop
three unwanted columns and those are key
mode and explicit and then we are going
to apply pieron correlation method now I
have set my figure size to 14 comma 6
and then we are using the C Bor heat map
function to create our correlation map I
have put
the variable that is correlation DF you
can see above we had created this and
then I'm setting annotation equal to
true so this will write the data value
in each cell I have set fmt equal to do
1 G so this is a string formatting code
to use when adding an anotations then I
have set my vmin and Vmax so these are
the values to Anchor the color map
otherwise they are inferred from the
data and other keyword arguments cmap
here stands for color map you can just
search for SNS cmap you will get the
documentation so you can choose
whichever color pette or the color map
you want here I have used info no and I
have set my line BDS and line color
finally I'm giving a title to my
correlation map and I have set the x
labels let's go ahead and run this to
get our first
visualization if I scroll down there you
go we have got
a nice corelation map so here on the
right side you can see the scale it
ranges from minus1 to + 1 minus1 means
the variables have least or negative
correlation while the values which are
above
0.0 means that the variables have a
positive
correlation
now here you can see there
are values like minus. 7 for energy and
acostic which means if the energy is
high the acostic is really low again for
loud Ness and say speech if the song is
loud the speech is low so there is
negative correlation but if you see for
energy and loudness there is really high
correlation between these two variables
you can see the value is8 so if the song
is loud this implies the song has really
high energy and vice
versa now if you see for a few other
variables there is negative correlation
between acostic and
danceability there is negative
correlation again between bance and
acostic similarly there is positive
correlation between energy and bance
which
is4 and even for danceability and
Valance that is positive correlation
which is5 cool so from the correlation
heat map you can note that acostic
appears to have a strong negative
correlation with with energy so if you
see for acostic and energy there is a
strong negative correlation and there is
a
moderately strong positive relation
between loudness and popularity so if
you see for popularity and loudness the
color is orange which means it lies in
this positive
region and there is also a moderately
strong positive relation between
danceability and bance so if you check
for danceability and bance here there is
uh moderately strong positive
correlation all
right now let's move ahead we are going
to sample our data and take just 4% of
the total data and we'll create two
regression plots using this data so let
me first sample my data so I'll create a
sample data
frame using my original data frame which
is dfdore tracks and say
sample I'm I'm going to use the int
function and see
0.004 multiplied by the length of my
original data frame which is
dfdore
tracks all
right now let's run
this and we
print the length of my sample data
frame if I run it you can
see 4%
of my total data set
is
rows
cool now we are going to create a
regression plot between loudness and
energy now in our correlation map we saw
there was a positive correlation between
loudness and energy which was point8
let's plot it in the form of a
regression line so I'll use PLT dot
figure I'll set my figure
size equal to let's say 10A
6 I'll say SNS
dot regression plot so I'm using the
function called reg plot and I'll use my
data as sample
uncore
DF give a comma and
say in my Y axis I'll have my
column
loudness and in the xaxis we'll have
energy
I'll give a color
to my data variable let's say the color
is
C then I'll set my title
to
loudness versus
energy let's say correlation
all
right let's make sure everything is
fine now we'll run and see our result
there you go so you can see here clearly
there is a very high positive
correlation between loudness and energy
on the y axis we have loudness and on
the x- axis we have energy
and you can see all the data points or
the songs
are in One Direction so if the energy
increases the loudness of the song also
increases and similarly if the loudness
of the song decreases your energy of the
song or the track also decreases so
there is a very high positive
correlation and you can see the
regression line here it has
gone and is increasing gradually
cool now similarly I'll just copy this
code and we are going to see another
regression plot this time for two
different features let's say we
have popularity in the y axis so I'll
say
popularity and then in the x-axis we
have let's say AC costic
I'll change the color to let's say B
which stands for
blue and we'll set the title
to
popularity
versus I'll have acos
thickness
correlation just scroll down and we'll
run it to see the result
there you go so I have
the different points for the songs and
here you can see the regression line is
downwards which means if the acostic of
the song increases the popularity
decreases and similarly if the
popularity increases acostic decreases
you can see the downward trend of the
regression
line all right
now in the next cell we are going to
create a new column called Year from our
release date column and I have changed
this to date time format let me just run
it
cool now after
that we are going to create a
distribution plot to visualize the total
number of songs in each year since 1922
that is available on the Spotify
streaming app so I have used my cbon
library and disc plot function now one
thing to remember you need to update
your cbon library
to this
version if you haven't done it so use
this command pip install D- user cbon
and the
version so here in the distribution plot
we're going to plot a histogram so Ive
used kind equal to hist which stands for
histogram let's run and see the result
okay so here you can see I have
my distribution plot so the plot tells
us that the number of songs for each
year in the data set according to their
release date have increased in the
recent years since music became more
accessible to people globally with
technological advancements so earlier
you can see there were very few songs
available in the
1920s later on the number of songs
increased rapidly and now you can see we
have a lot more songs available for
people to listen
cool
now we are going to see the duration of
songs over the years for that again we
are going to create a bar plot so I'll
first create a variable called total
duration equal to
dfdore tracks
dot I'll use the duration column that we
created with
seconds and
then I'm going
to
set
my figure Dimensions so I'll use figure
undor DMS for dimensionsal to 18 comma
7 after that I'll have
my figure AIS defined so I'll use the M
plot Leb subplots
function
and I'll set
the figure
size equal to my figure
dimensions and
then I'll say figure equal to SNS dot
I'll use the bar plot
function and say my x-axis to be
yours my Y axis will be total duration
or total undor Dr that we created here
I'll set my Axis equal to
ax and then then I'll set error
width equal to
false let's set the title for my plot
as title equal
to year versus
duration and finally I'll say PLT do X
sck I'll rotate it
by let's say
90° all
right let me just recheck once if
everything is fine and then we'll go
ahead and run
it my access error width
title okay let me just run
it we'll see the result in a
moment if I scroll down you can see we
have the bar plot for the different
years and the duration of the songs in
seconds in the y axis so earlier in the
1920s you can see the duration of the
songs were less and later it increased
around late
1930s and this remained consistent until
2010 where the duration was high but
after 2010 you can see the duration of
the songs have started
decreasing now in the next cell I'm
going to create a line plot to analyze
the average duration of the songs over
the years it is going to be similar to
our bar plot just that now we are going
to visualize it in terms of a
line so I have my code ready you can see
here I've used my cbone library and the
line plot function in the the x-axis I
have years and in the y axis I have
total duration I've set my title to year
versus duration and I'm rotating
my X labels by 60° let's run it and
we'll see the
output there you go now if I scroll down
you can see we have a
nice line plot and on the x-axis you
have the ears and on the y axis we have
the duration you can see that the songs
from
1920s to
1960s have comparatively shorter
duration since most of the songs tended
to be more singing based rather than
instrument
based after 1960s you can see the
duration of the songs started increasing
until I would say
2010 and in the present day the duration
of the songs have started declining
since the attention span of the average
listener is also declining all right now
let's move to our second data analysis
project which is based on geners of the
songs so I'm importing my data set using
the pandas read CSV function I have
given my location and here I have my
data set name followed by the extension
of the type so this is a CSP data set
let's go ah go ahead and run
it okay now let's print the first five
rows of the data set I have stored my
data set in a data frame called dfdore
Jer I'll use the head function to get
the first five rows of
information I'll hit shift enter to run
it there you
go you can see here I have my Jor column
artist name track name track ID
popularity
acostic duration in milliseconds again
and we have the rest of the other
columns that we saw in our first data
set just one thing to note here key is
present in terms of c d e c minor F
minor and not in terms of numbers
between 0 to
11 now we'll see
the duration of the songs for different
genes for that I'm going to create a bar
plot so I'll start with setting the
title for my plot as
duration
of the
songs
in
different
geners I'll use the
cbon
library and I'll set
my color palet to let's say
rocket give a comma and say as cmap
equal to
true this should be color
palette
now I'll say SNS dot bar plot in the y
axis I'll
have
joner and in the x-axis I'll
have my duration column which is in
milliseconds so duration underscore Ms
and then I pass my data frame using the
data argument so I'll say data equal to
DF do
Jer
next we'll set the x labels so I'll say
PLT do X
label let's say my X label is duration
in
milliseconds and then I'll say PLT Dot
by label as
Jers now let's go ahead and run
this there you go so here you can see we
have the different Jers on the y axis
and on the xaxis you have the duration
in
milliseconds and if you see the graph
for classical genre and for songs that
belong to World genre the duration of
the songs are more compared to other
genr now if you check for children's
music genre the duration is less or the
least
cool and
finally we'll move to our last demo
where we'll see see the top five geners
by
popularity so I'll say SNS do set
uncore
style I'll set
my style
to
dark
grid which will be my
background and then I'll see PLT
dot figure I'll set my
figure size
to 10 comma
5 then I'll create a variable called
famous since I want to take only the
most popular songs based on the Jer so I
have created a variable called femas and
I'll pass my data frame name that is
dfdore Jer and I'll sort the values
based on my popularity
column so I'll
say
popularity and I want to sort it in
descending order so I'll say ascending
equal to
false and I'll take
the
first 10 values I'll tell you the reason
why I'm taking the first 10 values and
not five
then I'll say SNS do
barplot and in the y axis I'll have
Jer in the x-axis we'll
have
popularity and I'll give a comma and
using the data argument I'll say my data
to be famous which is this variable that
we
created and then I'll set
my
title
as top five
genners by
popularity all right now the reason why
I took head of 10 is because there are a
few gen which are repetitive so if you
see this we have children's music
appearing twice so hence we have taken
10 instead of five let me just go ahead
and run it there you go so here if I
scroll down you can see I have my top
five genres based on the popularity so
we have dance pop rap hip hop and
rigaton so these are the five genn which
are most popular based on the data that
we have collected from
Spotify all right welcome to the simply
L YouTube channel channel in this
session we will learn how to create a QR
code and then learn how to decode it but
before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit the Bell icon
to never miss an update and before
starting let us have a simple question
to brush up on our knowledge and please
answer in the comment section below we
will update the correct answer in the
pin comment and your question is what
does QR in QR code stand for and your
options are quick record quick response
quick review or quick restore you can
pause the video give it a thought and
answer in the comment section now moving
on let's learn a few facts about QR
codes QR codes are quick response codes
used to store information that can used
to make a call send a message or email
open a website or even redirect to a
location and a QR code can store up to
4296 characters or 7089 digits in a
single code making it viable to hold
large amounts of
content let's see how a QR code is
generated on web we will open the
browser and search for any free website
that is used to generate QR code we will
search QR code
generator and we can enter any any URL
or any text to just create a QR
code so we'll write simply
learn and you can see your QR code has
been generated you can download it copy
it and send to anyone and he can just
scan it and see the TT simply learn to
check it we can
also open a QR Scanner in a mobile
phone for that we'll just just write QR
Scanner in our Google Chrome or any
browser and open any free one and
just scan
it you can see that it has scanned and
decoded it as simply learn what we have
encoded in it so let's move and create
our own QR code scanner using python for
that first we'll create a
folder
and name it as creating QR
Scanner and inside it we'll open the
command prompt
and open Visual Studio
code I have chosen the visual studio
code as my data you can choose any like
jupyter notebook or P Cham any dat and
inside I will create the
file and name it as QR Scanner
dopy and now the first thing we have to
do is import the python
modules so for that the first module we
would be importing is python QR
code I will write the command pip
install QR
code as you can see that it states that
the requirement is already satisfied I
have already installed the python
package you can use this command to
install that and if you face any issues
just comment down in the comment section
and we'll get back to you
now moving to our Visual Studio
code we will import the
package
import QR
code and now we'll use the function make
to make a QR code for that we'll write
QR
code do
make and inside we'll just copy any URL
link or any command any contact
information or anything so we will go to
a
browser and open the
YouTube and search for creating a
virtual
assistant and
python
and
will copy this
URL and paste
it in the make function so that will get
the QR
code of our own video that is creating
virtual assistant using
python now we'll save
this into a variable and name it as my
QR and get this variable saved as a PNG
image so that we can get it in our
folder as our folder only contains the
python file
now when we save
this that's PNG file
now you have to save your code and just
run
it you can see that my qr. PNG has been
generated so just open it you can see
that you have got your QR code
generated and you can
also make some options that is scale I
will set the
scale equal to
you'll save the file and run
it and you can see the QR code
scanner
now we
will use a mobile phone you can use any
mobile phone Android or iPhone and just
check
it using any QR code scanner that is
available on your browser or you have
any other app you can use that
I'm using a free version on my web and
that is QR code scanner.
in and on scanning I got the link and
when I open
it I am redirected to the video that is
how to create a virtual assistant using
python so we have successfully made the
QR code scanner
now we have made the QR code scanner and
we can also decode it using the python
libraries so for
that we have to install two more
modules that is piar and
pillow for that we'll write the command
pip
install
byar
you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied as I have already
installed these modules and we also
installed pip
install
pillow this is also installed and if you
face any issue in installing these
packages just comment down in the
section we'll get back to
you now moving on to our Visual Studio
code
now
we'll use the class decode first we'll
import the packages
on
from
P
doar import the decode
class and
From
Below
import the image
class
now moving to decode the QR code we will
use the decode class from P
bar and use the image
class
and open our PNG file that is what you
named as my qr.
PNG
and
now we'll store it in our variable that
equal
to and now we'll print what is decoded
what would be decoded and we'll just get
the value for that we
will get the information at the zero
index that is
data we will decode it
in s
key so yeah now
we save our
code and run it here you can see that
you have got this link that is recorded
what you have encoded in the QR code
scanner and now I have a question for
you to just check whether a QR code is
working or not now you have to
make a task to just scan the QR code and
see whether it's working or not for that
we will create my QA
1 equal to QA
code do
make and
inside we will get a link for our
website
now we'll save the file and run
it and get
also as a image for that we'll write my
qr1 do
save and the name of the file and add a
scale of seven we'll save the file run
the file here you can see that the QR
code has been
generated
and we have get
it pasted for you guys so just scan the
QR code and check whether it's working
or
not so just scan it and answer as yes or
no in the comment section
below if it's working just answer it yes
else
no hi everyone welcome to the simply L
YouTube channel in this session we will
create a QR code scanner using python
but before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit the Bell icon
to never miss an
update and before starting a project let
us have a simple question to brush up on
our knowledge and please answer in the
comment section below and we'll update
the correct answer in the pain comment
and your question is what is the minimum
decodable size for a QR code
scanner that is QR code only and your
options
are
1.5 by 1.5 CM or 1X 1 cm or 1.75 by 1.75
CM or 2 by 2
cm you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section and moving on now we'll start a
project that is create a QR code
scanner for that first we'll create a
folder
and name it
as creating QR code
scanner and inside we
will open the command
prompt and write a command code space
period and press enter to open our idle
that is I using the visual studio code
you can use any idle
as you comfortable
with and we'll create a file and name it
as QR
scanner.
py and now the first thing we will do is
install the modules that we will require
for the project for that we will open
the command
prompt uh the first module we will
install is open CV
and you can search for the command in
the web or if you know you can just
write it down and press enter for that I
will show you how to get for the command
you can just type open
CV Python and press
enter you will see the first link that
is open CV
python that is the original
documentation and you can see the
command here just copy
it direct to the command
prompt and paste the command here and
just press
enter as you can see that it states that
the requirement is already satisfied I
have already installed the open CV
module you can just type in the command
and press enter it will just install it
for
you and the second one module we will
install is is p
bar just open the official
link and you can see the command here P
install pbar just copy it and redirect
back to the command prom and paste your
command here and just press enter it
will do the work for you as it is stay
that it's the requirement is already
satisfied I already installed the asbar
module you can do that just writing the
command and press
enter now moving to our Visual Studio
code now we'll start with our code and
we first we will import the packages the
first package we will import is that is
the CV2 that is the open CV
the next we will import the decode class
from the P bar module so for that we
will write the
command
decode now
the first thing we will do is uh we will
create a variable and ask the open sa
module to make the video capture
function work for us for that we will
create the variable and name it
as
cm and the command would be CV to
dot video
capture
now we will set the window this is the
window that would be reflected when we
just make our camera equal to true that
is camera is always defaulted as false
you have to make it true to get it pop
it on your windows
screen and for that we will set the
size cam do
set and first we'll set the width and
we'll set the width as
five and set the pixels as
640 and now we'll set the
height cam do
set and height as six and pixel as same
um hold
480 as you wish you can set it as and
now we will make the camera equal to
true as it is a button for a camera and
it's been defaulted set as false we have
to make it
true now while
camera is equal to equal to
true we will read the QR code scanner we
will read the QR code that we will show
in our front
camera so for that we will write the
command when camera equal to equal to
true that is when the camera is
open we would get two things that is
success and the
frame and that would be equal
to cam dot
read it will read the frame that would
be shown into our camera and the success
is it will return the Boolean value that
is one or Z and the frame is it would
read the frame as captured by a front
camera and decode
it now to decode it we will run a
r
for
I we will make it as
decode and inside we will pass the
frame that is the frame captured by our
camera
and print the
type that is uh which type it is that is
it's QR code or its bar code or it's uh
any other code so it will just capture
the frame and it will return or print it
as which type it
is
now we will
print what we will decode from the QR
code for that we'll write the command
code do data what data is stored in
it and we'll use the function
decode and the memory we would be using
is UTF
8 oh sorry uh we have taken it as
I
and now after we have read the frame and
recorded it we want it to sleep for some
time for that we will just import the
time module and you can install the time
module from the date time module you can
just write the command pip install date
time or you can just search on the
Chrome or any browser about the datetime
module and python you can just write
date time space python space module you
will be just directed to the main
documentation and you will get the
command there and you can just copy it
and paste it in the command prompt and
the rest would be done for you as I've
already installed it I will import the
time
module and now make this Frame
sleep for about 6
seconds
and
now we
want to make or show the
camera uh on a window it should be
popped up and we should be able to see
it for that we will use the open C
module and write the
command I'm sure and we will name the
camera window with our QR code scanner
you can name it anything as you
want so I will name it as
R
qore code uncore
scanner and the next thing we will do is
pass the frame in
it
and we will just write another command
that would
be weight key
function that would be we will using the
open save module and the weit key
function and this would be used to
capture the frame after the 3
seconds so this is our code we'll save
it and make it run
okay we C an
error okay this eror is due to as I was
using the front camera for recording and
it was not able to capture the
frames so I have
switch off the front camera the
webcam and now we will again save the
file and run
it now you can see that the webcam has
open up and now we will show it a QR
code and you can see that it has
concluded its data as
https ww. simply.com I have created the
QR code in my mobile
phone and made it available to the
webcam and it has showed us the output
as HTTP ww. simply.com we can
just press on click
and click on the right button of the
mouse you can we will be directed to the
link hi everyone I'm amarja and welcome
to the simply L YouTube channel in this
session we will create a MP3 player
using python but before we begin if you
love watching Tech videos subscribe to
our Channel like the tutorial and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
before we start I hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section and before starting first we we
should have a look on what we would
create so for that we will move to our
code simply run
this you can see that the take interment
has appeared and this is our media
player we have named it simply music
player we have the GIF that would be
running
continuously and we have the browse
music button which will direct you to
the any folder you want to open that
have the MP3 player
files I've selected this folder it has
four files and we'll play here there
just click on that and click on the play
button it will play the
music now we'll just click on the post
button so this is our MP3
player so before starting the
coding I have a simple question for you
guys
so moving to
that so the question is who wrote the
poem Zen of
python and your options are Tim bernly
Tim Peters Gan rusam or Kevin
Goldsmith you could see the poem here
also you can easily get this poem you
just have to write import this in your
interpreter and just press henter you
will get the
poem so please answer in the comment
section below and we'll update the
correct answer in the pin
comment you can pause the video give it
a thought and answer in the comment
section so moving to a
code first we will create a
folder and name it as create create MP3
player using
Python and
inside we'll open the command
prompt and write the command code
space sorry period and press
enter this will open up the editor that
is Visual Studio
code if you want you can use any edor
you have hands on any edor you can use
anyone and here we will create a file
and we will name it as player. py
only and we would require music also for
that and some GFS and some images for
our buttons you can easily get those
images from any free images website or
you can just get them draw in the paint
or photoshop them you can arrange them
from
anywhere so we have a piic in this
folder so we'll copy all these and we
have the music
folder it has four files and this is the
copyright free music so we can play on
YouTube we will past this in a folder
only that is create MP3 player using
python
yeah moving back to our Visual Studio
code so first thing is we should install
the python packages before starting our
coding so we would require the take
enter package it is already installed as
you install the python if you want to
install it again
just go to your
terminal and write the command pip
install
TK as you can see that the requirement
is already satisfied so I don't have to
install it again you can install it just
writing the command and press
ento and the next we have to install is
the py game to import the mixer
class uh sorry the command would
be pip install py
game and press
enter you can see that the requirement
is already satisfied I already install
the pame module you just have to write
the command and press enter you will get
them installed very easily and the next
module we need is
time so you can install the date time
module or the time
module it's your
wish so we have to write the command
we install date
time so it was not installed on my
system it has been installed
and it doesn't have
some classes in the module it has
installed them and it says the
requirement is already satisfied for
other modules
okay so
now and the last
OS
module install
the this window is not going so we will
just go to the
terminal
okay just c a
terminal and write the command here
pip
install
OS s s and press
enter so it will install the O module
for you
it is doing for me right
now and we would be using the tein
module to create the GUI and teiner is a
python module that is used to develop
graphical user interface and as I told
you there's no need to install it it is
the part of the standard python Library
so it would be installed as you install
python on your
system so it's downloading till then
we'll just import our
packages first we'll
import time and that we will use in to
get the GIF set up in a
GUI so we'll import the time and from
tier we will import all the
classes
and we will import the field
dialogue and from py game we'll import
the mixer class to get a buttons
functioning to make an mp3 music video
music like MP3 file to start playing to
pause it and to resume it again so for
that we write the
command from P
game import
mixer it's still
downloading till then we'll import the
OS
also it will get
it downloaded and installed for
us so first we'll create the ti to video
uh window for that we'll write the
simple command root equal
to
PK and circular brackets and get the
command root to main
Loop and if we save it and run
it oh sorry it was
[Music]
downloading just post
theing okay we'll see it again so you
can see that the take enter window has
appeared on the screen it's the
output it's a simple take of video now
we will add for functions to it we will
add size to it we will add background
color and we'll do other functionings to
that so take inter provides many methods
and one of them is geometry method and
it is used to set the dimensions of the
take inter window as you have
seen so we will just position the main
window on the users desktop we will use
the command root. geometry for
that
set the size as
cross that is X
only and for y axis it would be
700 and
now would get it 290 Point shifted from
xaxis
and 10 points shifted from y-
axis and we have to put them in inverted
kasas we will save the file and run it
again you can see that the T enter
window has changed its geometry and it
has set the x-axis as 485 5 and Y AIS at
700 and when it appeared it was
290 as see what dimension it uses it was
290 points apart from the x-axis and 70
sorry 10 points apart from Y axis yeah
290 and
10 so now we'll give the title to this
window for that we'll write the command
rot.
title and just write the
title you want to give it you can give
it
anyway so we'll name it as simply music
player and now we'll use the configure
function so take into configure function
it is used on any widget to change
settings that you may have applied
earlier or haven't applied yet so for
that we'll write the
command root do
configure and we will set the background
color
so
write
background equal to and inverted commas
we'll write the hexa code for this
color
we setting the gray color for a
background we'll save it and run the
file so you can see the output so we
have set the simply music player as the
root title of our T window and we have
configured background color at
Gren so moving
on now we will use the resizable method
it is used to allow tick enter route
window to change its size according to
the user's need as well as it will
prohib like it will not allow you to
change the size of the window the window
you just saw on the screen that was a
take inter window so we'll use the
resizable function and we will prohibit
will not allow anyone to change its
Dimensions so for that we'll write the
command
do do
resizable false
comma false so in resizable method user
can pass either positive integer or true
to make the window resizable to make
window non resizable user can just pass
zero or false we have passed false so
our window won't be resizable we save
this file and run it again you can see
now we can't resize it so first I will
command this command and save it and run
it for you
guys
you can see that you can resize it now
but after we write this
command no one is allowed to resize the
ti window we'll save
this and run it you can
see now no one is allowed to resize this
window you won't get any
option so now
moving on as you have seen the previous
dimensions and the demonstration of the
simply music player we'll create as same
as that
only so we will place the GIF here a
label here and place the buttons on that
and beneath that we will just create a
label and browse all the files
there
so we'll start with the
frame for that we'll write the
command first we'll create
a variable and name it as lower frame
and a frame is a rectangular region on
the
screen it can be used as a foundation
class to implement complex widgets it is
used to organize a group of widgets so
we'll be creating a frame and we'll
Place different buttons on that that
would be the play button post button and
the stop button and the volume that is
just the
image we'll place the volume image there
so lower frame equal to we'll write
frame to get a frame and inside we'll
pass
Loot and get a background color as
white that will write the hexag
code Ash and the hexa code for white
color
is FFF and that is six times you can go
and search on the web about the hexa
codes like which color is associated
with which hexa code or you can just
write the simple name of the colors you
can get your background set as well that
also
and here we'll set the width for our
frame so width will set as 485 only it
should cover the whole window in X
dimensions and for height we'll set it
as
180 we'll create the same simply music
player as I have shown in you as I have
shown the demonstration earlier
so we have set the height as
so now we will use the place method that
allows you to explicitly set the
position and size of a window or
anything like we are just creating a
frame so it would use to position and
size of the frame it would be either in
absolute terms or relative to an the
window so for that we will write the
command
first we will get the
frame that is stored in the lower
underscore frame variable and use the
place function to place it in our take
window and write the dimensions for that
we would start from X = to
0 and place it at y = to 400
now we'll save the
file and run
it okay we have one window already
opened so I closed it you could see that
this is the frame we have set it at xal
to 0 and Y = to 400 so it would
measure as y = to 0 here and y = to 400
here so we have placed the frame now we
will place the buttons on
that and first we will
set a logo for simply music
player that we
have in our
folder so this is the logo for our
simply music play where we will set it
so that we'll write the
command first we will create a variable
and name it as image
icon and here we will use photo
image
so like after writing the photo image it
would like it would create a photo image
object and you can use it in other
widgets that accept an image argument
that is some buttons they accept image
argument photo image argument you can
use the images there also and the image
object is returned by the photo image
function it's the easy to display a
picture in Python however the photo
image class only supports the GIF and
PGM PPM formats which is a concern jpeg
jpg and PNG are the formats that are
most often
used so
now in the photo image object we'll just
write the location of the
file as we have it in the same folder so
we'll write the name only that is logo
space
PNG and the extension that is PNG
only now to get it set as icon photo
we'll write the command root do icon
photo
and pass the argument as false
comma image and _
icon now we'll save the file first we'll
close the previous
one and run it you could see
that the logo has been placed
there so now moving
on we will create the menu
will again run the file so here we will
create the menu to browser
music so for that first you'll create a
variable
menu and create a photo image
object and write the file name only
as here we don't have to set the part as
all the images are in the same folder
only so for this we will use the menu.
PNG that is the white image I will show
you what we will get as
output
so we have to place this in inverted
commas
and now for this we will create a
label so inle in some widgets can
display an image such as label and
button so Ting in enter label repeat in
take enter label is a widget that is
used to implement display boxes where
you can place text or
images so we will create a label here
and place the menu. PNG image on that so
to create it we'll write the command we
have started with label and inside we
will pass
root and the
image
we'll write the variable name here that
is
menu and now we will place it we'll
position it in our take enter window so
for that write the command
place and
inside write xal to
and dimensions
are
okay so y would be
580 and we would also set the width and
height for that and the width would be
485 so it could cover the
whole sorry I didn't write the
width that would be 485 and now we'll
set the
height I will set as 100 only guys it
would
be in the bottom
section
so it won't get much height so we'll
save this and run the
file you can see that we have created a
label here also and a label here also
and we have pasted the white image place
the white image on that
label so this is the label that is of
the white color and now we have placed
another image on of another
label so I will show you what for what
purpose we have done
that so first we will create a
button that
would be for the browse
music that will write first pass rot and
then what text we want to show on that
button that would
be B
music and then we will set the width of
that
button that would be
59 and
then would set its
height
and set the height as one
only and now you you can
set font also like which font you want
to get displayed on that button for that
you just have to write
F equal to and start the circular
brackets and inside you can
write which font you want I will go with
Cali and font size would be
12 and I wanted
bold so in inverted commas I will write
B and outside this circular
bracket I will set the foreground
color that is the text text color only
foreground color as
black you can write the hexa code or
just write the name of the
color and we'll set the background color
as white for this
button use hexa code
here that is 6
MFS and now what function does this
button
do so it will show us the music that
would be stored in our folder we will
browse the folder and it will show us
the mp3 mp3 files that would be
contained in that
fold so in command we would write the
name of the function that we will create
to get all the MP3
files so we
will
is add music
only now outside this bracket we'll
place
it it's showing error as we have
not defined the add music function so
we'll place
it at xal
to0 y = to
now add scroll
bar so that when we get all our MP3
files we can just browse just by
scrolling so we can get all the MP3
files on that small window we will
create now so we'll set the scroll bar
for that for that write the
command scroll
bar and
inside get
a frame
music so
first
we set another
frame or and we will get it
as gray color only with that we will
write the command frame underscore
music we'll create a
frame and inside we will pass
root and set the Border equal to
two
and
[Music]
relief
equal to
ra so we have set the relief equal to
Rich so relief is a style and it's a
style of a widget that refers to certain
simulated 3D effects and we are giving
the 3d effect to a button and that
effect is Ridge so so we will see that
but before that we have
to get our add music
defined
so on you won't get the take enter
window as we have to define
the and
music so we have created the frame and
now we will place this and after that we
will create that
music
function for this we will write frore
music that was the variable name and
period place and now we will position it
in a take window so we want it at xal
to0 I equal
to so would place it
at 5
85 and we so Define its width and
height so width would be
485 and
height
100 so we were creating the scroll bar
so first we'll create create the scroll
bar and then Define the add music
function so now we will set the scroll
bar in the frame
music variable as we want the scroll bar
in that frame I will show you in the
demo only after I create the ad music
function so first we'll create the add
music function only
so we will create it
here add
music
and first we want that it should have
path and here we would
use file
dialogue so it would pop out the dialog
box
box to the directory with which we would
assign or take it
to
next right
if our
path
change directory
pass the path
here Source equal
to
do list of
directory
what
okay we have problems here but now we
disolve them so first if the path we
have
chosen and here we will change the path
and in this songs variable we'll get the
list of all the
[Music]
songs in that
directory and
now we
will create or run a for Loop for song
in
songs but all the songs we
got f
s ends
with
MP3 that is to
MP3 get playlist
do
insert will
pass and the
process and pass the
song so we
will get this playlist variable working
and another function that would be the
play music
function so it should play the music for
that
we'll create the
function
play
music create a variable
name that would be music uncore name and
inside get playlist do get and make it
active
and
now we
will print music
name and this would be printed in the
terminal
first pass active that is which music is
playing
and now you use the mixer
class and music do
load function and pass the
playlist the function notk and get it
as
active
and now here we
will
plate now we're getting errors for
playlist so
first cre the playlist variable that
would be having all the songs in
that so with that we will
write a variable playlist and that would
be equal
to it would have the list
box equal to
list
box and inside we will pass
the frame that we have created for
music and set its
width that would be equal to
100 and now we will set the font for
that
so can see all the names of the MP3
files in the same font only and for that
would
write Times New
Roman and set the font size as
10 and and outside this bracket we'll
set the background color for the
playlist that write
PG and we'll set it as gray
only
so exxod for GR
is
3333 3 and that is six
times we'll close the inverted commas
and set the foreground
color as gray
only select
background that would be of the light
blue
color
set the
cursor hand to I will explain you what
this
means first we'll set the
Border equal to zero
only T scroll
command that would be equal
to light
blue now we will set the Y scroll
command
that would be equal to scroll do
set so it should be used to
scroll so we have set the cursor equal
to hand to that means that it would
convert to hand when we scroll on the
list boooks that is when we would try to
select any of the MP3 player files it
would show us the hand
cursor
and the background color is light blue
we have set and scroll command equal to
scroll do
set okay now we will configure
it
okay maybe we have some errors we'll
resolve them and we will see the output
also just after this
so first we will configure the scroll
bar so that we'll use variable only
scroll.
config and
inside we will have the command equal to
playlist
do y view so it should have in the Y AIS
only and
now back the scroll
bar P it at
right
and fill the y
axis for that we'll write
fill equal to
Y and now we will P the
playlist playlist do
p place it
side equal to
right and it
should
fill both the
sides it should be
filled so that will write the
command which cannot appear after
keyword
[Music]
argument okay we'll get it sorted
save the
file run
it so you can see
that we have the browse music button
here and if we click it we have the
functioning it
will we will select the
folder create MP3 player and this is the
folder that is music and we'll select it
it has four
files I will show you in that also so
this is the folder it has four
files it is displaying us all the four
files and you can see that we have the
cursor as hand here that is we have set
it as hand
to so now we will do other functionings
that is place the JF run it and place
the buttons so first we will place the
buttons and run
it so for
that after this Frame music we'll start
with the
buttons so first we'll create the play
button for that we will create a
variable and name it as button
play and we will use a
photo a picture for that button that
will create a photo image object and
pass the file for it and we have that
file name play
1.png so we'll just write the name of
that file and invert it
commas and
now we
will set the
functioning set the button we'll pass
root and the
image is equal to the variable we have
set it for that that
is button
play capital for
play
and we'll set the background color for
the
button that would be white only because
we have the white label
here so it would be perfect for that and
now we'll set the
border that would be equal to
zero and
okay we have to place it in inverted
commas else it would
be functioning as a comment Only We have
set the border that is equal to zero now
height
okay H H
HT oh so just forgot the spelling of
height okay so I have to declare the
height first so we
will get these buttons in 60 for 60
Dimensions only we'll set the height as
60 and
width also as
60 and now we would set the command for
this button so what functioning should
it do for
that we will write the function name
that is play music
[Music]
and now we will place
this at X =
to
215 and Y =
487 and we have created the play music
function above and see that it has the
function
to play the
music we have used the mixer. music. Lo
from the P game and it would get the
playlist and the active contents there
and it would play
it so we are done with a play
button we'll save it and run the
file so take window is opened first we
close
that started so first we'll browse so
this was the folder music we'll select
this folder you can see we have these
four files we'll click on the one and
just click on the play
button
okay uh we forgot to add one
functioning so
first we
will create all these buttons and then
add all of
functionings now we will create the
second
button that would be the stop
button for that
we'll create a variable and name it as
button
stop and here also we'll create a photo
image
object pass file and inverted
Comas and we have stop 1.png for
this so we'll just write the file
name and in the next line we will Define
the functioning of this
button so inside button we will pass
root and
image that is the
variable button
stop and set the background color equal
to White
only and then that would be in the
inverted
commas and now we'll set its
border that would be
zero and height and width would be 60
only and after that we will set it
command that would
be mixer
do
music dot stop so we are using the mixer
CL the music class inside that and the
stop
function and now we'll place
this I take into window with that we'll
write the dimensions for that X = to
130 and Y = to
487 so we have created the stop
button we will save this and run the
file you can see that the stop button
is also displaying on a TI
window and now
we will make a third
button that would be the pose
button for that we'll use the pose one
PNG this is the
image so for
that just Cy these
things
place it
here so
button po equal to photo image and we
will use the
image POS
one.png
and get
it only as set all other as
big so button pause background color
white order zero height 60 withd 60
command would B mixer do music.
POS and we will place it
at 300a
487 we'll save this file
file and run it you can see that we have
the post button displayed
here now we will get the volume button
not the volume button just the
image so this is the image volume. PNG
we will get it there so for that we will
create a variable
volume
one and create a photo image
object and set the file
location and the location is it's
already placed in the same folder so
we'll just write the name of the file
that is volume.
PNG and that would be in the inverted
commas
and
now we will place
this
at X = to 20
and Y = to
487 now we save this and the
file so we are having some
errors okay uh we can't directly use the
place
here so
first we'll create another variable and
create a label for this
image so for
that we will use panel
and equal
to side will pass root
comma that is equal
to volume
one and
now we will use the place
and place it
at X =
[Music]
to that was
at 300
and Y would be
700 that would be
487 so now we'll save this file and run
it
you can
see
okay we have made a mistake
here
so it should be here so X would be less
it would be around 20 and why would be
same for that
only so we'll change
that save
this and run the file again
yeah you can see that we have the volume
image we have the play button the post
button and the stop button we will get
the J working for
us and now we
will get our GIF working but before that
we will make the mixer initialize so
that uh buttons they should function
that is play pause and
stop so we have imported the mixer class
so we will initialize
it we'll save this and run the
file now you can browse the
music click on the any MP3 file and
click on the play
button you can hear that the music is
playing so I will pause
it and now we will start with the
functioning of our
GF uh so we have to cut the previous
part and
now start with frame
count so the frame count of RG GF is 30
and we will store it in a
variable and now we'll create another
variable as frames and
inside we start with square brackets and
create a photo image
object and inside we will pass the
file the GI file
file the name of the file is a1.
GF and here we have to specify the
format of the
file for that we'll write
format equal
to
andas
GF one
index
and we'll set the
index and
I so we would be using the list
comprehension
here now we will run the loop
so for that we'll write for
I in and use the
range of the frame
count so what we will do is the GF has
so many Mes in that so we have to run a
loop so it would again repeat itself
as the frame count would be equal to the
count as the images would be repeated in
a loop we will set the count equal to
zero and repeat it again so for
that now we'll create a
function and name it as
update and inside we will pass a
variable
and create a variable with name frame
and
inside we will
pass I
variable
mames
and as this image would be displayed we
will
increment the
variable and
if I is equal to equal to frame count
that is if it has displayed all the
images in the
GF we will set it at zero
and run it
again and we would set the gfn label so
we will configure
it and we have to define the label
also so for that we write
label equal
to label and said we pass the
root and now we'll configure
it and pass
image equal to
what frame we
have currently
like and
now
we will use the after
function and pass 40 milliseconds so
that the animation would start
again and pass the update
function the current
IND and now we will place the
label and x = 0 and Y =
0 and again we will run the after
function and pass 0 milliseconds and the
update function
function the zero
frames
okay
expl
this live statement
only
okay first we have
to place the label statement above
now
yeah now we are done with that
GF
save
this and run the
file so we are getting an error
here
okay
so
subd okay we'll save this file and run
it again
okay in code
displayed so we have this label
above just browse the files select the
folder and click on any file and just
click on the play button you can see
that our MP3 play is
working we just set the Joi
again you pause
it you could stop it
so we
will get
this
[Music]
downwards
starting with the buttons now we'll save
the
file and click on run
button you can see that the GF has taken
the whole
frame and now we'll browse the
files you selected the folder and and RF
statement will find the MP3 files and
click on the file just
the you can see that our simply music
player is working
fine so I will share the code link with
you in the
description hello everyone I am M and
welcome to Simply learn today we will
take you through the hand on lab demo of
how you can create a speech to text or
speech recognition system using python
before we start I hope this screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them I'm
repeating again before we start I hope
the screen is clearly visible and the
audio is fine if yes please type in yes
if there are any issues do let us know
in the chat section so that we can
resolve them let's wait for some more
minutes to let other people
join yeah until then let me tell you
guys that we have regular updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hun for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
I'm repeating again let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply
learn it I think we can get started so
in today's session we will go through
what is a speech recognition system
moving forward we will see how speech
recognition system works after that we
will create a speech recognition system
using python we will perform different
function and create speech recognition
system using different python libraries
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what is the speech
recognition system first and proceed
further for the
same what is a speech recognition
system a program capacity to convert a
spoken language into written language is
known as a speech recognition system
also known as automatic speech
recognition computer voice recognition
or speech to text despite being
sometimes confused with voice
recognition speech recognition focus on
converting speech form a verbal to a
text format whereas voice recognition
only aims to distinguish the voice of a
certain
person voice and speech recognition are
two distinct Technologies and they
shouldn't be confused to recognize word
in spoken language speech recognition is
used voice recognition uses biometrical
Technologies to recognize a specific
person by their
voice so after knowing what what is the
speech recognition system let's move
forward and see how does the speech
recognition system
work peace recognition in Python works
with algorithm that perform linguistic
and acostic modeling acostic modeling is
used to recognize phonetics in our
speech to get the more significant part
of speech as words and sentences speech
recognition start by taking the sound
energy produced by the person speaking
and converting it into the electrical
energy with the help of microphone it
then convert the electrical energy from
analog to digital and finally to the
text it breaks the audio data down into
sounds and it analyze the sound using
algorithm to find the most probable word
that fits that audio all of this is done
using natural language processing NLP
and neural networks hidden markup models
can be used to find temporal patterns in
speech and improve accuracy so so here
is one question for you guys I will give
you one minute for this you can comment
or you can give your answer in the chat
section so I can see if the answers
given by you are right or wrong I'm
repeating again so here is one question
for you guys I will give you exactly 1
minute for this you can comment or you
can give answer in the chat section so I
can see if the ansers given by you are
right or wrong so the question is which
of the following is the correct
extension for the python
file I'm repeating again which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file option a python option
BPL option C py and option D
P so let us know your answer in the
comment section below so I'm starting a
timer of 1 minute just type your answer
in the comment section or in the chat
section do let me know your answers
please I Curly ask that everyone take
part in this to make this live session
exciting so I'm starting the
timer you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see if the answers given by you are
right or wrong so the question is which
of the following is the correct
extension of the Python file
37 seconds remaining option a python
option BPL option cpy option
D.P let us know your answer in the
comment section
below I cly ask that everyone take part
in this to make the live session
exciting you have 15 seconds
remaining 10 seconds more
which of the following is the correct
extension of the Python file 3 2 1 after
that a lotted time has passed Those Who
provided the correct response will
receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one okay so now let's move to
our programming part to create a speech
recognition system using python so first
we will open a command prom to write a
command to open Jupiter notebook so here
we will write Jupiter
notebook press
enter so this is the landing page of
jupyter notebook and here you can select
new python
file so this is how the jupyter notebook
UI looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating a speech
recognition system so here we will write
right first let me remain rename
this speech
Rec so first I will import
import
speech
underscore
recognition and second
import pyttsx3
enter so the incredibly exension I
repeat the incredibly extensible speech
recognition Library serves as a rapper
for a number of well-known speech apis
the speech recognition Library includes
default API key for one of these the
Google web speech API hardcoded that
implies that you can start moving
without needing to register for a
service and python project would benefit
greatly from using the speech
recognition package due to its Verity
and
usability and then pyttsx3 a python text
to speech conversion library is called
pyttsx3
it is compatible with python 2 and
Python 3 and work offline unlike
competing libraries to obtain a
reference to a pyttsx3 engine instance
an application calls the pyttsx3 in it
it is very user friendly program that
turns type text to into
speech so moving for let's write code
for actual speech recognition system so
here I will
write Sr equals to
speech
underscore
recognition dot
recognizer R must be Capital
here
yeah there I will write with
speech
underscore
recognition dot
microphone
Source
two then
colon
yeah
here I will write
print
we write here okay
silence
please okay then I will write here Sr
dot
adjust underscore for
underscore
ambient underscore
noise then source to comma
duration equals to
2 okay then
enter then I will print something
like
peek now
please something like that then I will
write here
audio audio
2 equals to
Sr Dot
listen Source
2 and here I will write for text equals
to
Sr
dot
recognize
okay
underscore
Google audio 2
then here I have to print the small
letters in lower case so I will write
here text equals to
text
lower
this then here I will write
print it you
say
plus
text uh everything look
great so a recognizer is a machine
ability to listen to spoken words and
identify them you can then use a speech
recognition in Python to convert the
spoken words into text make a query or a
give a reply you can even program some
devices to respond to these spoken words
like every time the recognized speech
from mic function is invoked the
recognizer is calibrated for changing
noise condition using the adjust for
ambient noise this one for ambient noise
the backlog parameter of the listen
function allow a quiz size to be
specified it will listen to what we are
speaking or
saying this recognized Google a function
on the recognizer class which you have
now developed will be used to query the
Google web speech API and convert spoken
words into text recognize Google needs
the argument audio data in order to
function properly otherwise it will
fail python built-in function lower is
mostly used to handle strings the lower
method converts each Capital character
in The provided string to lower case
before returning the lower cast string
it accept no arguments it return to the
original text if the supplied string has
no capital letters
now let's check whether it's working or
not so I will run it yeah run
all hello how are you
doing yeah you can see hello how are you
doing
printed so let me try another
one
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply
learn so here you can see subscribe to
Simply learn YouTube channel and press
that Bell icon to never miss any update
from Simply learn is
printed so speech to text is working
fine so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any questions or any
queries regarding any code or you have
any questions just put as in comments
our team will shortly provide you with
the correct solution now moving forward
what if you want that system will write
what we are saying and speak that to
this will be printed and now moving
forward what if you want that system
will write what we are saying and speak
that to so for that we will write a
small line of code so first we will
do we will create one here like we will
insert cell below we will write a
function here so
DF Speak
Now
command colon then voice equals
to pytt
sx3 do
init okay then voice do
say
command
and
voice do run
wait
yeah so what we will do
here we will write like
speak
now
then
so this voice is nothing just a variable
to text to speech and in it pytt X3
engine has started obtains a pointer to
an instance of an engine that will
utilize the specified driver if another
engine instance is already using the
given driver the other engine instance
is return if not a new engine is built
is speak now is a function in which
using get function I'm getting the
values of the text this one I will get
now let's run this sort of code and
let's see if it is working or not so I
will
run hello how are you
all PE now is not defined
okay speak now okay and is
small okay my B runs is again
hello how are you
all hello how are you all I hope you can
hear properly so let
me run this again for another demo
example subscribe to to Simply learn
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn subscribe to simple and YouTube
channel and press the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from simple learn yeah
so I hope you guys understand toer if
you have any question or any queries
regarding any code or you have any
question related to python just put as
in comments our team will shortly
provide you with the correct solution
okay okay moving forward so at last
let's create a speech recognition system
from which we can open our websites and
all like YouTube like Facebook like
simply learn anything so we will open
open new file for this I will create the
separate
one where I will write speech to web
websites
okay
speech to
web so here I will import import speech
underscore
recognition then import pyttsx3
then one major Library
import web
browser okay then I will run it yeah I
hope you already know these two first
two libraries so this is third librar is
used for web browser is the file source
code the web browser modules offers a
high level user interface that enables
user to view web-based content in most
cases executing the open function from
the this module will result in the
desired
outcome so mov moving forward let me
write code for it so I will write code
first then I will explain you line wise
so I will write
if underscore
uncore name then again 2 underscore
equals to equals
to underscore main then again
underscore then
colon yeah then you have to give a path
like for your browser you can use Edge
you can use Google Chrome anything
Firefox anything so here I will give
path path equals
to
then C drive I have my path
already
program
files and x
Microsoft and
Edge
then okay
then
application then
msh
exe you have to write at the end this
percentage
s don't forget to write this okay so
path is set so let me create Sr equals
to
speech
recognition do
recognizer same as previous
one and I will write with speech
underscore
recognition dot
microphone
as
Source then sr.
adjust
or
ambient
noise then
Source now everything seems
good let me write print
but we have wrote there like speak now
please so here I will
write
please say
something to
open
okay I will write audio
equals to sr.
listen
listen that
source and I will
print like what you
said so it will hear
[Music]
hearing and I will here I try and accept
then try so here I will write
destination equals to
Sr dot
recognize underscore
Google then
audio
print where you
asked to
open write here plus
destination okay so then
web
browser web browser dot get that
path then
open that
destination
destination okay
so here I will write that
accept
exception exception
as you can write
e then
print if there will be
error
st
e
okay so a recognizer is a machine
ability to listen to spoken words and
identify them you can use speech
recognition in Python to convert the
spoken word into text you can even
program some devices to respond to these
spoken words every time the recognized
speech from mic function is invoked the
recognizer is calibrated for changing
noise condition using the adjust ENT
noise method a socket is already to
receive connection after calling the
listen function prior to performing the
accept method on the server socket the
listen method should be called the
backlog parameter of the listen function
allow a q size to be specified it will
listen to what we are speaking or
saying the recognize Google function on
the recognizer class which you have now
developed will be used to query the
Google web speech API and will convert
spoken words into text recognize Google
needs the argument audio data in order
to function properly otherwise it will
fail okay so okay so let's try this it's
working or not let me run
this okay invalid syntax perhaps you
forgot a
comma let me
see that print
error think it should be
here okay let me check
this
let me run this
again Val it syntax perhaps forward a
comma
okay
try to run this
again
two okay let me remove this I guess it
will work fine
still
did input okay okay no
issues so here I will write
again
accept
exception
e
and
erors okay I forgot to write plus okay
okay
e yeah now it will work
fine
www.youtube.com
here you can see YouTube is
open yeah so we will try this one more
time
www.fb.com
so here you can see Facebook is open
ww.facebook.com
one more last
time
www.s simplylearn
do.com you can check our amazing courses
on different different Technologies here
on simplylearn website simply
learn.com so I hope you guys understand
till here if you have any query any
question of regarding any code so just
put as in comments our team will shortly
provide you with the correct
solution okay I'm repeating again I hope
you guys understand till here if you
have any questions or any queries
regarding any code or related to any
python question so just put as in
comments our team will shortly provide
you with the correct solution I hope you
guys must understand how to create your
own speech recognition system using
python if you have any queries you can
ask in the comment section below our
team will shortly respond you as soon as
possible and if you want this full code
if you want this full code so just
comment for the same thank you so much
for being here if you enjoyed this video
please do subscribe to our YouTube
channel and give a like to this video
today we will take you through the
Hands-On lab demo of how you can do the
sentimental analysis of Amazon customer
reviews before we start I hope the
screen is clearly visible and the audio
is fine if yes please type in yes if
there are any issues do let us know in
the chat section so that we can resolve
them let wait for some more minutes to
let other people
join let's wait for some more minutes to
join let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on multiple Technologies
if you are a teag gig on a continuous
hunt for the latest technological Trends
then consider subscribing to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
great I think we can get started so in
today's session we we will go through
the what is sentimental analysis after
that we will see types of sentimental
analysis we will see some application of
sentiment analysis and at the end we
will see Hands-On lab demo like how to
implement sentiment analysis using
python in detail we already have Amazon
Customer data set with us we will
perform different function and analyze
data for sentiment analysis using python
you can download data set from the
description box below so before we move
on on the programming part let's discuss
what a sentiment analysis actually is
and proceed further for the
same sentiment analysis sometime known
as opinion mining is a technique used in
natural language processing NLP to
determine the emotional undertone of a
document this is a common method used by
organization to identify and group ideas
regarding a certain good service or
concept text is mind for sentiment and
subjective information using data mining
machine learning and artificial
intelligence tools for sentiment
analysis assist businesses in extracting
information from unstructured
unorganized language found in online
sources like emails blog post support
tickets web chats forums and comments
algorithm use rule-based automatic or
hybrid technology to replace manual data
processing while automatic system use
machine learning to learn from their
data rule-based system execute sentiment
analysis using
predetermined lexicon based rules
combining the two method result in
hybrid sentiment
analysis sentiment analysis or opinion
mining can extract the subject opinion
holder and polarity or the degree of
positivity and negativity from the text
and identify sentiment additionally
other Scopes including document par
paragraph sentence and Subs sentence
level can be used for sentiment analysis
after seeing what is sentiment analysis
let's discuss some types of sentiment
analysis so the first one is find grain
sentiment analysis by segmenting
sentiment each phrase or clause in a
sentence is broken down and examined in
relationship to the others simply said
you can tell who review a product and
what topics a person specifically
discuss in their feedback and the second
one is emotion detection instead of
identifying positivity and negativity
emotion detection recognize particular
emotions example could include shock
rage grief frustration and happiness and
the third one is intent based analysis
in addition to identify opinions in a
text the intent based analysis also
identifies behaviors for instance a
frustrated online comment about changing
a battery can motivate at customer care
to get in touch to address that
particular problem and the last one is
expect based analysis collect the
precise component that is being
mentioned either favorably or
unfavorably for instance a client May
write in a product review that the
battery life is too short the system
will then respond that the battery life
is the main complaint and not the
product as a whole so after seeing types
of sentiment analysis let's see some
application of sentiment
analysis organization can employ
sentiment analysis Technologies for a
number of purpose such as determining
brand popularity reputation and
awareness at a particular period or
overtime customer service requests into
categories and the next one is
monitoring consumer response to new
improvements or products and the fourth
one is identifying the demographics or
Target Market and the fifth one is
determining the effectiveness of a
marketing
effort so here is one question for you
guys I will give you one minute for this
you can comment or you can give answers
in chat section so I can see if the
answers given by you are right or wrong
so the question is is text analytics
also refers to as text mining I'm
repeating again is text analytics also
refers to as text mining the options are
true
or
false so let us know your answer in
comment section below or in chat section
so I'm starting timer of 1 minute just
type your answer in comment section or
in chat section do let me know your
answers so I'm starting timer of 1
minute I kindly ask that everyone take
part in this to make this live session
exciting so the question is is tax
analytics also refers to as text
mining 35 seconds are
left do let me know your answers I
kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make the live session
exciting
you
want 20 seconds
left you can comment or you can give
your answer in chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong so time up guys so after the
allotted time has passed those who
provide Ed the correct response will
receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one okay now let's move to our
programming part to perform sentiment
analysis using Amazon Customer data set
so first we will open command prom to
write command to open jupyter notebook
so here we will write
Jupiter
notebook press
enter okay it's Jupiter
notebook
so this is the landing page of jupyter
notebook and here you can
select new python
file it's loading
so this is how the jupyter UI looks like
so at first we will import some bunch of
major libraries of python which will
help us in mathematical functioning so
the first one is numai so first I will
write numpy import
numpy
NP N is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has
functions for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numai stand for numerical
python so the next one is
pandas I will write here
import
pandas s
PD so so pandas is a software Library
written for a Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structures and operation for
manipulating numerical tables and time
series after that we will
import
nltk so the natural language toolkit
nltk is a Python Programming environment
for creating application for statical
natural language processing NLP for
parsing classification stemming tagging
and semantic reasoning it includes text
processing
libraries so after that we will import
from
nltk dot
sentiment
Vader
import
sentiment
density
analyzer okay there is no colon yeah so
the Lexicon and Rule based sentiment
analysis tool Vader Vader means Valance
aware dictionary and essential reasoning
is a customized precisely to Sentiments
expressed on social media Vader makes
use of variety of a sentiment lexicon is
a collection of lexical elements such as
words that are often classified as
either positive or negative depending on
their semantic
orientation Vader not only informs us of
the positivity and negativity scores but
also of the sentimentally of each
score so the next one is
import
re python re module fully supports
regular expression similar to those in
Pearl if a regular expression
compilation or use error occurs the re
modules raises the exection
re two key functions that are used to
manage regular expression will be
covered so R means regular expressions
so the next one is
from X
blob
import
okay so a python 2 or three package
called text blob is used to process
textual data it offers a straightforward
API to explore typical natural language
processing NLP
tasks like part of speech tagging noun
phrase extraction sentiment analysis
classification translation and
more so the next one is
import
words
from word
cloud a word cloud commonly refers to as
a tag cloud is an image of words popular
words and phrases are highlighted using
Cloud creators depending on their
frequency and importance they give you
immediate straightforward visual
insights that can Inspire more through
analysis and the next one is
import
cbor
as
SNS yeah
so like an open- Source python Library
based on mat plot Li is called cbon it
is utilized for data exploration and
data visualization where data frames and
the panda Library C Bon function with
ease so the next one is import met plot
lip dot P plot
as
PLT okay yeah seems good for Python and
its numerical expression numai met plot
lip is a crossplatform data
visualization and graphical charting
package as a result it presents a strong
open source substitute for mat lab the
apis for matplot lib allow programmers
to incorporate graphs into GUI
applications and the next one is
import pu links cff l n KS as
CF perfect another python module called
cuff link links plotly with panda so
that charts can be easily created on
data frames in essence it function like
a
plug-in so next in
line at BL lip
at plot
clip so you can enable inline plotting
by using the magic function percentage M
plot Li in line which causes the plots
and graphs to appear below the cell
where you plotting commands are entered
similar to a jupyter notebook it offers
backend interactivity in front ends the
next we will
import what you can like we can import
okay
from shortly dot
offline
import init underscore
notebook underscore
mode comma I
plot okay in it underscore
notebook
mode gets through
yeah
cf.
goore
offline
so yeah in order to display the plot
inside the notebook you need to initiate
plotly notebook mode as follows like
this keep rest of the script as it is
like it and run the notebook cell by
pressing you can shift plus enter graph
will be displayed offline inside the
notebook so basically it is used for the
offline graphing you can see okay so
next we will
import from
plotly do subplots subplots are
important
import make underscore subplot
okay yeah the non-leaf nodes in this
figure schema are represented by a
hierarchy of python classes that was
automatically constructed and is found
in the plotly do graph objects which is
normally imported as go these class
instance are refers to as graph object
the plotly defined fundamental
classes
okay so here we will for some like uh
warnings you can
[Music]
say like to get not
error so we will import let me give a
line space
import
warning warnings yeah
warnings dot
filter
warning
ignore warnings do
one
and this uh like will not
show and let me add something
PD do
set option
display do
maxcore
Lums okay import import words from
wordcloud okay there's an error let me
check what's the
error
okay
import
this
wordcloud from
wordcloud it's
capital and W is also
Capital here will be
Capital let it put is small
only
from
wordcloud okay my bad here from
wordcloud from
wordcloud import
wordcloud
okay yeah seems good
so where were
we yeah in warnings despite the
notification the software continues to
execute to display warning messages
utilize the warn found in the warning
module the python built-in class
expection is a subass of the warning
module which is used to display warning
messages import warnings okay for seeing
full data every single columns like okay
there is error
cbor no module l c
so s will be
small got it okay in
line is only
like something like that in
line okay any errors no I guess no error
okay yeah for seeing full data like
every single Columns of PD so here we
are using this pd. set option so we can
use for it so moving forward let's
import data set so for importing data
set we will write
here
uh like DF equals to PD dot read
CSV
Okay add data set
name
so so you can download data set from the
description box below so no worries of
for
that let me run this
okay so like here is PD is for Panda's
Library read is used for reading the
data set from the machine and CSV is
used for the type of file which you want
to read so let's see our
data so here I will write DF dot
head
yeah so if you want to like if you want
to see top five rows of your data set
you can use head and if you want to uh
like see five rows of your data set you
can use tail inser instead of head this
one okay so this is our data set with
only five rows if you want to see full
data set you
can like from starting from zero and
ending it 4914 rows okay 49115 rows and
12 columns
right so let me give something like this
for the better
visual
yeah okay so moving ahead let's sort
this Wilson bound column to ascending
order for better analysis so I'm talking
about this Wilson lowerbound column this
one for it's not 0 0 0 like in all the
rows so let me show you
so here you have to write like DF equals
to DF do
sort Val
use
Wilson spelling should be
correct
lower
bound I make it to ascending
order
ascending sorry descending order
so BF do
drop
named
okay
uname colum
zero okay in
place in place equals to true
comma XIs = to
1 okay so let's see your
data so here you can see the data is
sorted in
as in as ascending order
okay so the provided row or column is
eliminated via the drop function the
drop method eliminate the specified
column when the column AIS is specified
the drop method eliminates the
designated row when the row xes is
supplied okay so I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
queries or like any queries regarding
any code or there is something question
till here just put as in comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct
solution
okay so moving forward let's make a
function for missing
values so
okay so I will write here like
DF
missing
values
analysis
analysis okay it's DF for function we
use
DF
yeah
F A
columns Wass
to co for
columns
for or Co n d F dot
columns if
DF
column is
null do
sum is greater than
zero underscore
missals to
DF na underscore
columns
underscore is
null dot
sum dot sort values sort underscore
values like in ascending
ascending ascending equals to
True like
some be like this and
this that's fine I
guess
yeah so here I will write
ratio underscore equals
to
DF
nacore columns
underscore do is
null same thing that
sum divided
by
F do
shape
Lev
sort
values
standing to true
fine okay
okay is okay and the TF
part that sort value is equals to
sending to True fine
so here we will write missing
underscore DF = to
PD dot
concat dot
round
ratio underscore comma
perfect their XIs will be one
okay
is equals
to I will give
like total where I will write missing
values
missing
values okay comma
ratio
thing underscore DF equals to PD dot
data
frame go
DF okay so let me
return d
f let me create one more function for
like check data frame so
DF Che underscore data
frame
okay equals to
5 comma
tail equals to
so here I will write
print
okay
okay do
center2
comma and for Rose
Sprint
r
craes dot
format what
format
do
shape
Z so for columns
print
do
shape
and and types like of types of
data
Dot
Center same as like that
[Music]
ENT DF do D
types
Center just printing this this like you
will see don't
worry just stay with me you will see the
beautiful
result okay
print
values print missing values uh
analysis this is like
DF
okay
then
again
values like there's many how many
duplicated values are there so dot same
for the center
again this
one
print have dot
duplicated don't worry I will explain
you like like by line just stay with me
let me write the whole code first
print
tiles like I'm printing multiple of
things so just be with
me
ENT
comma
EF
dot
onti
comma
okay
check data
frame I'm hoping like there will be no
error
yeah so you can see now like
multiple information regarding data set
is
printed so this shape is for like how
many rows and columns present in the
data set like in types you can say like
every column type like object n 64 float
64 and many more are like present so
like you can see review text is like
object and dat difference is N64 and
we'll lower bound is float
64 okay so total missing
values so total missing values are like
uh one from here and one from here like
one in from reviewer name and other is
from revie
text and like there is no duplicated
values in our data
set and here you can see so like after
that quantiles a quantile defines a
particular part of the data set that
that is a quantile determines how many
values in the distribution are above or
below a certain limit special quantiles
are the like quartile quarter and you
can say quintile that the fifth one and
the percentile which is from 100 okay so
quantile is for like
quarter or the you can say the fifth one
so why I wrote this 83 82 and this for
this purpose for making this something
look cool that is
why okay
and
yeah so moving
forward let's see unique values and in
each column okay so I will write
def
check
plus
frame
unique fals to PD dot
data
frame
variable
the
frame columns
comma
classes
colon
data
frame
I I will write like n
unique
U
or I
in data
frame
columns like n
unique
[Music]
Q DF equals
to
sort values
cles Comm
ascending equals
to
false
okay n
unique underscore DF equals to n
unique EF do
reset index
drop equals to
true
return an
unique qu and
un
DF Jack underscore class which one
DF
so let me run this
first yeah it's running you can see
here okay there is an error
classes
okay check class
DF is
saying this
is
Okay C is capital c is
small let we run now
yeah so here you can see the every
column having unique values are sorted
in descending order like review Tex have
like more unique values so it come first
and then reviewer name reviewer time
date difference Wilson lower bound score
average then goes to
overall okay moving forward let's do
some categorical variable analysis for
overall okay so this will be like
amazing something amazing is going to be
happen
so on strands equals to so I'm giving
here like some color values
so B3
4 d
22 e b 00 C okay so you can change you
can like write whatever you want
color hashtag oh I didn't write hashtag
here
hash three
Comm 0
C 92
E
EB
z
c and then D you like five
right okay so DF let's make function
Okay small
DF
categorical
variable okay DF
comma
column okay categorical variable summary
yeah perfect so let make some figures so
make
subplots
plots rows equals to 1
comma
calls to
two let me write from here like
subplot
metals
to count plot
like one for
percentage
okay so specs
spe equals
to okay like
type
colon
why
okay same
type col here
domain
figure.
add and then
[Music]
Trace go
dot
bar like one bar and one that pie chart
okay y = to
DF
columns
name
values do to
list for X you can L
string yeah s
Str
I or
I
in
column
name
value
counts
xtals to
DF colum
name do
value counts and then
bracket dot
values dot to
list
okay so for
text
font the size should
be 14 is enough I
guess so
column M go
name X
position so I'm doing for like making
chart
so stay with me to see that amazing
chart okay so show
Legend
to
T
color to
constants so these are the like colors
so I'm giving here value like V variable
name
con
strs
line equals
to it's
hasht DB
e 6
EA one okay
small
okay let me just like go over
through everything is correct or not for
the column
name very count index yeah it's fine
text equals to DF column name
do value counts do values to to list
okay text font equals to T size then
okay 14 size is enough name equals to
column name and text position equals to
Auto and show Legend Falls and
Mark dict like color equals to constant
okay F line equals to color and this
yeah this okay
cool row = to 1 comma column =
1 it seems
good like for pie chart we will make
figure dot add so this is done for the
like line chart not line chart that bar
chart and this I'm doing for the pie
chart okay
Trace go
dot
Pi F
columns column
name
value
isuse to
DF again that column
name
value
count
counts and Dot
values nextext
font
take size
I will prefer 18 is
enough
Exposition like Auto is
fine so
Legend to no need of Legend false
name equals to column
name column
name let's to like d then colors
go to
constants = to
one columnal to two like in second okay
you will see and you will get to know
don't worry so figure dot
update layout
equals
to
Colum
n.
five
comma
X
should be on
Center and Y
anchor be on
top let
shortly
okay I
plot
figure let me run this okay like call
equals to
two now let's see the chart of like
column overall one so we will write here
categorical okay
variable
summary and then data frame name DF
comma overall
okay let's run
this okay it's loading here it's
loading yeah you can see this is this is
our bar plot and this is our pie
chart
so like this is
overall uh from overall you can say that
column
so like
percentage bar and that bar plot so this
is how our like pie chart and bar chart
looks like I hope you guys understand
till here if you have any questions or
any query regarding any code okay like
any code any sort of code so just put as
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct
solution so moving forward our goal is
to rank the com comments by the
sentiment analysis so we don't get hung
up on the other details I have sorted
this data set according to certain rules
before so moving forward we want to
clean our data so let's see the sample
data for
cleaning so DF
dot
review
text okay dot
head let me run this so so this is our
sample simple data looks likees so let's
see like data full data for this okay
let me see
for what this I guess
okay or like any particular row you can
say I can take okay so I will write
review _
example
example equals to DF
dot VI
you text uh I will take a random 2031 my
guys okay so
review underscore
example so this is like at
20131 there is one review text okay so
in that the whole data is here like uh
like so my lovely wife bought me a
Samsung Galaxy Tab for father this this
this this like to find the exact model
number this is a long you know command I
got the this this this it works like a
charm okay
so after seeing this data what we're
going to do is like we will clean it
from punctuation and numbers using Rex
Rex what regular expression okay so here
I will write review uncore
example example
okay equals to R do
sub and what I will do
is okay I will explain don't worry small
l
to capital
A A to Z
okay comma then
space comma review underscore
example
example add
sorry
yeah
view so here we used re for regular
expression okay and so all the
punctuation and numbers are removed from
particular
data so let me check
first okay this A to Z then A to Z okay
fine so like all the punctuation and
numbers are removed from particular data
I will now convert the text to all lower
case our machine learning algorithm
recognize words that start with the
capital letters as a different word and
we will convert them to lower case so
thus our machine learning algorithm will
not perceive words that start with a
capital letter as a different word so
what I will do is here I will write
review
example
example equals to G
[Music]
view again
example
lower I will
split
okay yeah
example so here you can see we have
converted all the words in the lowercase
letter by using lower function and why
they are coming in new lines because we
are splitting them using split function
okay if you see only did lower case for
single row like we did for the like 20 I
guess 20 31 okay yeah so let's make all
row same in lower case so I will write
here r D equals to
Lambda
X
St
Str
X for
DF
view
text is capital
text
DF
view
text
XT okay equals to
DF
view yeah do
lower have dot
head see all the data is in like lower
case so I printed just top 10 rows and
in like in reviews text column all the
are in the lower case now so I hope you
guys understand till here if you have
any question or any query regarding any
code or question till here like any code
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
and if you need this full code you can
comment down below
okay so now the time is come to do
sentiment analysis because all the data
is
sorted so what will I write
here let me do it little bit up
yeah so I will write
from yeah from
Vader
sentiment do
B
sentiment
intensity analyze
okay
have
polarity
subjectivity
subjectivity to
DF
VI you
text
apply PD do
series okay here you like text
blob then again
text
do like
sentiment let me run for Loop for
index comma
Row in
DF G VI
text what it
items
for
sentiment
density
analyzer
polarity
scores
row netive I
score or neutral I will write
score if for
positive
if this is something crazy if negative
is greater than
positive then DF do
location
index
comma
sentiment equals
to
negative
negative okay
then El
if positive is greater than
negative then in this case DF Dot
log
index
comma
sentimentals
to
positive B
capital
else EF do LS
see
index
ENT
to
neutral
Okay so like this is for sentimental
analysis and text blob this thing like
text blob this blob okay
blob text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity polarity indicates your
mood that is whether it is positive or
negative or neutral it returns a value
between 0 and one the closer to one the
more positive and the closer to zero is
more negative okay let me run this it
will take a little bit time because this
sentiment okay it is getting ER RoR like
module Panda has no attribute series
okay which
one text
box XT just
sentiment okay here what is this the
thing s is
capital let me run
now it is
executing like fit for a while
wait so it will take time to run because
like because of this sentiment intensity
analyzer it take
times G sentiment
intensity analyzer okay spelling mistake
again
why index index is not
defined sorry
again
index
it will run I guess because everything
seems
good negative positive and this
else loading so I have to wait like for
like 2 minutes more I
guess
still loading
guys it take
time sentiment intensity
analyzer so let me tell you again
sentiment analysis like this text
blob text blob we return polarity and
subjectivity so polarity it indicates
your mood that is whether it is positive
it is negative or it is it will be
neutral it returns a value between 0 and
one the closer to one the more positive
the closer to zero more negative okay I
guess is
still
running so it will take time so let me
write code for that uh 20 interpretation
I repeat moving forward let's identify
the 20 interpretation now we can include
the positive negative and neutral status
of the command okay then
DF
timent what equals to
positive
start use
son
lower
sending equals to
false
okay dot
head
five if I will run it
may give error to me because it's still
running still running here it's still
loading
so let let let me write code for that
unbalanced data problem so like we will
category that data into positive
negative and
neutral Okay
so
categorical
variable
summary
DF
ment yeah it came like this because of
this wait I will tell
you
yeah so here you can see the pie chart
distributed in negative positive and
neutral emotions okay or you can say
ratings and here you can see the bar
chart also
so and you can see the percentage
distributed in each like in positive
negative and neutral one so I hope you
guys must understood the concept of
sentiment analysis how we can implement
it using python hello everyone and
welcome to this really interesting video
on football data analysis project using
python this is going to be a live
tutorial now in this video we'll be
performing a handson demonstration on
analyzing and visualizing the English
Premier League data set for the 2020
2021 season which is the last season of
eepl let me show you the data set first
that we'll be using for our demo
session all right so here is the eepl
2020 2021 season data set that we'll be
using for our demo so the First Column
you can see the names of the different
players that play in the English Premier
League so we have around 532 players
participating in the eepl last season
then the second column is about the club
that belong to you can see we have the
different clubs first is Chelsea we have
Manchester City Man United Liverpool ler
West Ham United Tottenham Arsenal and if
I scroll down you can see the other
clubs such as
the clubs like Aston Villa we have
Everton wolver Phantom vandros we have
Crystal Palace and
others now coming to the third column
which is about the nationality of the
players that is the Players belonging to
the different nations we have England I
think this is Sagal Germany we have
France Spain Italy Brazil Croatia and
others
now the fourth column is about position
that is the position at which these
players play at now you can see some of
the players play at different position
they can play for two different
positions like for example Mission Mount
from Chelsea plays as a midfielder as
well as a forward now Edward meny is a
goalkeeper DF is for Defender son and so
forth now next we have the age of the
players we have the total number of
matches played by each player in the
last season of eepl then we have the
total number of starts the player got
that is whether the player was part of
the playing 11 or not then we have the
total number of minutes the player had
played in the last season of EPL this is
the total number of minutes the player
had played next we have the total number
of goals scored by each player we have
the total number of assists given by
each
player then we have passes
attempted the percentage of passes
completed up next we
have total number of goals scored from
penalties and then we have total number
of penalties that were taken now we have
two different columns XG and XA so XG is
the expected number of goals from the
player in a match and x a is the
expected number of assists from the
player in a match and finally we have
the last two columns total number of
yellow cards received by the player in
the last season of EPL and then we have
the total number of red
cards received by the player in the last
season of EPL that is 2020 2021 so we
are going to use this data set and we'll
be analyzing and answering specific
questions such as the total number of
goals scored the total goals scored on
penalties and the total goals that were
missed uh while taking penalties then we
have players from different nations
playing in EPL then we'll also look at
which clubs have the maximum number of
players in the squad we'll be also
analyzing the players based on their age
group then we'll see the
total goals scored by the top 10 players
in the last season of e and we'll be
visualizing these results with the help
of different charts like the bar chart
the pie chart and we'll also
create plots using libraries like cbon
and matplot lab so let's head over to
our jupyter notebook let me show you the
jupyter notebook that we'll be
using cool so this is my Jer notebook
that I'll be using for this live session
today you can see I have renamed the
notebook as eppl 2020 2021 data analysis
demo and and I have some of the cells
filled already this is to make sure we
save some time cool so first and
foremost let's go ahead and UT the
necessary libraries that we'll be
requiring for our demo so first I'll
import the data manipulation Library
which is spanned as PD and then we'll
import
nump as
NP then I'll have m plot
lib
dot
pyplot as
PLT after that we'll be importing the
second data visualization Library which
is cbon as
SNS finally I'll say
percentage Mac plot lib in line so we'll
get our results just right below the
code once we create the charts and
graphs so let me hit shift enter to run
this first
cell all right you can see we have
successfully imported the different
libraries now the next step is to load
our EPL data set so I'll create a
variable called _ DF which essentially
stands for data frame I'll say PD dot
since it's a CSV file that we just saw
I'll say read uncore CSV now within the
quotations we are going to pass in
the location of the file followed by the
file name and the extension of the
file okay so I have copied the file
location let me just paste it
here within the codes now we are going
to
give one
more back slash so that that it reads
the location
correctly I guess you don't have to do
this if you are
on a Linux or Mac system now after this
we are going to give two
more backs slash and we are going to
give the file name which is eplore 20
uncore 21 dot
CSV
cool now
next line I'm going to print the head of
the data frame that is the first five
rows of the data frame that is _ DF so
I'll say _ DF do head let's run it now
you can see the output we have the first
five rows printed from the data set and
you can see the different columns that
we have all right now in The Next Step
let's
check
the info function that will give the
total number of columns that are
there as well as display the total
non-null values in each of the columns
so I'll say
EPL
uncore DF
doino let's run it you can see we have
the different column names and on the
top you can see there are total 532
entries we have total 18 columns you can
see total of 18 columns these are the
total columns their column names and on
the right you can see the total number
of non-null objects which means we do
not have any null value in any of the
cells or any of the columns and at the
bottom you can see the memory usage and
the data types all right now let's go
ahead and use the describe function to
get some summary statistics about our
data set so I'll say _ DF do describe
let's run
it and now you can see we have the count
mean standard deviation the minimum
value the maximum value 25th percentile
the 50th percentile and the 75th
percentile now this describe function
only works on numeric
columns
cool
now let me show you a way in which you
can check the total number of null
values that are there in each of the
columns for that we are going to use the
is any function and over that I'm going
to use the sum function to get the total
number of null
values here I'll
see
eplore
DF dot I'll say is any a DOT
sum now let's let me run
it here you can see we do not have any
null values for any of the columns
cool now let me show you the process in
which you can create two more columns
such as the minutes per match and we'll
create another column that is the goals
per match so for that I'm going to first
call my data frame which is _ DF and
within square brackets I'm going to give
my new column name that is minutes per
match this should be a valid python
name I'll say equal to now the minutes
per match should be equal to the total
number of minutes divided by the matches
that is the number of matches played so
I'll say _
DF I'll divide
minutes by let me give a bracket here
I'll say
eplore DF and then I'll divided by
the matches
column and we are going to set the type
as
integer all right then the second column
I'll create is goals per match so I'll
say _
DF and my new column name is goals per
match equal to let's start with the
bracket we'll say eplore
DF we consider the goals
column and
then we'll divide it by
_
DF give a square bracket and
say
matches
and we are going to convert the type
as
float cool let's run it now if I
say
print
PL let code DF you can
see or let's say _ DF do head
to print the first five
rows here you can see we have
created two more columns let me just
remove this print statement and we'll
run it again now you can see we have
created two more columns that is the
minutes per match for each of the
different players and then we have the
goals per match for each of the
different
players all
right now
in the next cell we are going to
calculate the overall total goals that
were scored in the
2021 or 2020 2021 EPL season so let's
see total goals I'll create a variable
called total underscore goals equal to
I'll say
eplore
DF we're going to take
the goals
column and then I'm going to use the sum
function now let's
print
the
total
goals if you hit tab it will autoc
complete let me run
it
okay to remove goals now you can see
there were total 986 goals that were
scored in the last season of English
Premier League now let's find out out of
this 9986 goals how many goals were
scored in penalties so for that we are
going to use the penalty uncore goals
column I'll create a variable called
total
underscore
penalty equal
to we'll say
eplore
DF and then we are going to consider the
penalty uncore goals
column then I'll say dot sum to find the
total number of goals that were scored
in
penalties if you hit tab it will give
you a prompt let me select the second
one run it there you go here you can
see out of 986 total goals that were
scored in the EPL last season 102 goals
were code out of
penalties now in the next analysis we
are going to see the total number of
penalty attempts that were taken and how
many
converted so for that let's create
another variable called total
underscore
penalty
attempts equal
to now this should be the penalty
attempted column so I'll say EPL under _
DF and we are going to consider the
penalty
underscore attempted
column say dot sum to find the total
number of penalties that we taken and
we're going to use the print
statement let me hit Tab and I'll select
penalty attemps let's run it so overall
25 penalties were taken out of which 102
got converted the rest all were
missed we are going to create our
first plot in our live analysis about
the EPL 2020 2021 season so we are going
to create a pie chart for penalties
scored and
missed okay so first of all we are going
to set our plot
figure to a
certain
size let's
say I'll say figure
size equal
to and this will be at
tle let's say I'll say 13 comma
now I'll
see penalty not
scod equal to a data frame that is
_
DF I'm going to pass in
my
ntore attempted
column and then
Summit and I'm going to subtract the
total penalty goal
so that is total underscore penalty
goals say data equal to this will be a
list so I'll
say penalty not code let me just copy
and paste it comma we're going to pass
in
total penalty
goals also give labels to our pie chart
so the
labels will
be
penalties
missed is
scored make sure you put it within
quotations we are going to
give color to the
P chart so for that I'm going to use my
cbon library I'll say SNS do
colore
pallet say I'll set my color pallet to
set two you can check for different
color paletes just Google
caborn color palet and click on the
first
link if you scroll here you can see the
different
color
Petes you can see Tab
10 then you also have
hls H USL which is for hustle you have
set to paired let scroll down you have
rocketor R rocket you also have Cube
Helix then magma and others all right
let me come back so I'm using the set
two pallet and we'll see PL dot create
the pie chart we are going to use the pi
function and we'll pass in our data
followed by the labels parameter which
is equal to the labels that we have
declared above which is this
one
okay
now I'll say the colors parameter should
be equal to the color pallet that we
have defined in the above
line next we are going to use
Auto PCT so this autop PCT enables you
to display the percentage value using
python string formatting so you can use
the autop PCT to display your percentage
values let me give a certain
formatting percent dot
oof which is for string I'll give two
percentage
values finally I'm going to say PLT do
show to display
my
chart cool now let's run this okay there
is an error here which is
plot.
figure this should be plot. figure and
not
underscore there you go you can see we
have our first visualization for the
EPL data analysis
demo you can see 82% of penalties were
scored while 18% were
missed now
next we're going to find the total
number of unique positions for
which each of the players play for that
is this will also tell us the total
number of positions that are there in
football so I'll say eplore
DF let's consider the
position
column and I'm going to use the unique
function to find the total number of
unique positions that are there such as
the center forward
midfielder Defenders goalkeepers Etc if
I run it you see here we have
goalkeeper midfielder and forward
forward Defender
midfielder Defender and midfielder
Etc you can see some of the positions
are a combination of two positions which
means a few of the players play for two
different positions on the pitch all
right moving
forward we are going to see
the total number of forward players that
played in the last season of eepl so for
that I'm going to see
eplore
DF again within square brackets I'll say
eplore DF and we are going to consider
the position
column basically subsetting the data
frame to derive valuable
information now this should be equal to
equal to my value which is FW that is
forward let's run it there you
go so here if I scroll down you can see
see the different players that played
for there are total 81 rows which
means 81 players in the eepl played
as forwards you can see Teo Warner from
Chelsea Tammy Abraham Who currently
plays
for Roma in Italy we have olivo zerud
then we have Rahim
Sterling also have Billy Shard from
United and Daniel
also next question that we are going to
answer
is we'll see the players from different
nations so we'll see in
eepl what are the Nations or the total
number of nations from which players
come from so I'm going to use this
function called numpy do size and within
brackets I'll see eplore DF we're going
to to consider the nationality column to
find the
count so I'll say
nationality and we are going to use the
unique function to get the total number
of unique nations from which the players
play in the eepl if I run it you can see
here there are total 59 nations from
which the different players play
from now let's see the most players come
from which
Nations for
that going to create a variable called
nationality equal to I'm going to use my
data frame _ DF followed by the group by
function first we are going to group by
nationality column and then I'll say dot
size and we are going to
sort values in ascending
order so for that I'm going to use the
ascending parameter and I'll set it to
false which means we are going to print
in descending order and not
ascending
next I'll
say nationality. head since I want to
know the top 10 nations from which most
of the
players come
from we also so going to plot
it this should be a bar chart so I'll
say
kind equal to
Bar let's give
a
figure
size equal
to let's say 12 comma
6 and
now I'm going to say color equal to we
again going to use the C Bon color
palette pet so I'll say SNS do
colore
pallet and this time we are going to
choose let's say
magma all
right think everything is fine let's
just run
it great now if I scroll
down you can see the
different nationalities the top 10
nations from which the most players come
from of course since eepl is in England
or is it hosted in England so most of
the players are from England then we
have the most number of players playing
from France Brazil
Spain this is Ireland I guess then we
have Portugal Scotland Netherland Wales
and
Belgium
cool
now moving moving forward let's come to
the next cell we are going to see the
clubs with maximum players in their
squad this will tell us the clubs let's
say the top five clubs which have the
maximum players in their squad or had
the maximum number of players in the
2020 2021
season we're going to consider the club
column and we're going to count
total number of
players so I'll say
values rather value underscore
counts let's use the N largest function
to get the top five clubs and we are
going to plot it
again this will be a bar chart again so
I'll say kind equal to
Bar comma and we'll see
color equal to SNS do
colorcore
pallet let's choose a new
pallet
namely where it is so I'll write it
correctly b i r i d i s fine let's run
it and here you can see we
have West Brom which Alban which had
nearly 30 players in the squad
then Manchester United I think they had
29 players in their squad last season
then Arsenal with the third highest
number of players followed by
Southampton and Everton so last three
had the same number of players close to
29 or 28 all
right now similarly if you want to check
the clubs with the least players in
their squad we just need to use the N
smallest function here I can copy this
cell of code we'll just edit it instead
of n largest I'll say n
smallest
cool rest everythings the
same it you can see here
leads United had the least number of
players in their squad followed by
Manchester City Crystal Palace Tottenham
Hotspur and West Ham
United
cool now in the next analysis we are
going to see the players based on age
groups so we are going to Define four
age groups let's say
players less than 20 years of age then
players between 20 to 25 years of age
then we have have players from
25 and 30 that is 25 between 25 and 30
and finally we have the different
players who are above 30 years of eache
for that I'll create my first variable
which is under
20 this should be equal
to
underscore
DF I'll say eplore
DF we'll consider the age
column again we are subsetting the data
frame so I'll say less than equal to
20 then we'll have age between 20 uncore
25 equal
to
EPL
underscore
TF subset as e _
DF consider the age
column it should be greater than
20 I'll
say
ambus and eplore
DF use the H column should be less than
equal to
25 let's copy this
next we are going to see for age between
25 and 30 so I'll edit my variable name
2530 here this should be greater than 25
and less than equal to
30 cool finally we'll have
players above
30 equal to I'll say
eplore DF
within square brackets I'll say
eplore DF we'll consider the H column
should be greater than
30 cool let me run it and now in the
next cell which is already filled this
is to create the pie chart for the above
age groups that we created to see the
players based on different AG groups so
this is very similar to creating a pie
chart again so first of all I'm creating
an ump array for all these four
variables and we are going to consider
only the name then I'm setting my labels
as less than equal to 20 greater than
equal to 20 and less than equal to 25
greater than equal to 25 and less than
equal to 30 and then above 30 I have the
title as total players with each groups
let's
see the font size as 20
cool let's run it and you can see we
have our pie chart so from the pie chart
you can see the last season of English
Premier League at least 37% of the
players were aged between 25 and 30 and
then we
have 35% of players who were between 20
and
25 13. 3% of players were above 30 years
of age and we had
14.7% players less than equal to 20
years of
age now if you were to check the total
under 20 players in each Club so for
that I'll see
players
under
20 equal
to again we are going to subset our
original data frame _ DF I'll say
eplore
DF age should be less than
20 next we'll
see
p underscore under
consider the club
column then
values underscore
count let's
plot I'll
say kind equal to
bar and we are going to choose the
color will to SNS dot
color
pallet let's
say we'll go with Cube
Helix
cool okay let's debug the error there
are some errors it says series object no
attribute values underscore count this
should be value underscore
counts now let me run it cool you can
see there are
seven players or there were total seven
players in the Manchester United Club
who were less than 20 years of age
followed by five players in wolver
Hampton wanders then shff
United and the rest of the other clubs
you can see now let's find out all the
players who were aged less than
20 in Manchester
United well let me just scroll down cool
so here I'll
see
players
under
20 again we're going to see
players under
20 to subset based on Club equal to
equal to I'll give the value as
Manchester
United run
it and you can see the seven players
that we saw above here you could see we
had seven players in Manchester United
that were aged below
20 and the names are mission Greenwood
we have Brandon
Williams Ahmad Deo Anthony
Alena we also have William Thomas fish
cool and you can see that each is here
189 19 all of them are less than 20
years of age and similarly you can also
check for other club let's see you want
to see the under 20 players in
Chelsea we just need to replace or
subset our club for
Chelsea there are only two players who
were eached less than 20 Callum hatson
ooi and Billy
Gilmore
cool we're going to create a plot to see
the average age of players in each Club
so for that I'll say PLT
dot
figure take the figure
size as let's say 12 comma
6 then we're going to use the cbone
library and the box plot this
time the box plot is a good way of
finding the variability in your data it
will give us the mean the median the
25th percentile the 50th percentile the
75th percentile the maximum value and
the minimum value and the box plot will
also show if there are any outliers in
the data so my X will be Club my y value
would be age and my data will be my
original data frame that is
eplore DF I'll see PLT
dox
text and we are going to say rotation
equal to
90° let's run
it if I scroll down here you can see we
have the box plot so for chelse C you
can see
the minimum age value the maximum age
value and then you also have an outlier
here I'm assuming this is someone who's
aged above 36 or
37 and then here you can see
the
median and similarly you can see for the
rest of the other clubs now if you
notice I can see
here that
Crystal Palace has the highest average
each if you see this
line now this line is the maximum
Crystal
Palace not
verify the clubs with the average age of
players I'll
say let's say num underscore
player equal to EPL let me just scroll
down
score DF dot we'll use the group by
function
on
club and I'll
see
size to that I'll say data equal to _
DF or
then I'll group it by
Club
see
age
dot
sum and we are going to divide it
by the variable that we created above
that is num
player finally I'll say data do
sort
underscore
values
ascending equal to
false let's run it okay it has thrown an
error it says sort underscore values got
an unexpected keyword argument ascending
okay there's a spelling mistake this
should be
ascending there you go so as we saw
above in the box plot now here you can
see Crystal Palace has the highest
average age in that team which is 28.3
years then we have West Ham United
followed by bonley now if I scroll
down Manchester
United had
the least average age of players that
means they had a very young team that
played in the 2020 2021 season after
that there were West Ham Aston V and
other
clubs
great now in this cell we are going to
find the total SS from each club for
that I'm going to group by club and we
are going to find the sum over the SS
column after that I'm going to create a
bar plot in the x- axis we have the club
names on the y axis we have the total
number of ss then I'm setting the pallet
the color pallet to set two we have an X
label we have a y label
we have the font size for the labels I'm
going to rotate the x-axis labels by
75° we have the figure size set and the
title as plot of clubs versus the total
this should be
assist let me run
it and you can see here we have
the total number of asss for each of the
clubs as you can see Manchester City had
the highest number of assets which were
above 50 or around
cool let's
see the players who gave the most SS in
the last season of EPL so for that I'll
create a variable called top
ssal to I'll use my frame name _
DF followed
by name then
Club
then this
column and I also want the matches
column and I'm going to use the N
largest function to find the top 10
plos so I'll say n equal to
columns equal
to
SS let's print the top 10
SS let's run it okay again there is an
error let's debug
it see it's invalid
syntax let me
check
Club Assist matches then we have
enlarges equal to n equal to
10 columns equal to
assist
and this should be a
comma cool and here you can see we have
Harry Kane from the last season of EPL
who gave the maximum Sage that is 14
followed by Kevin
de Brun from Manchester City who gave 12
assists followed by Bruno Fernandez from
Manchester United is a Portugal player
and he gave 12 assist song hung men from
Tottenham hoser he played for South
Korea and he also gave 10 assist Jack
GIS gave 10 assist then we have Marcus
rashford Jimmy VY Timo wner and other
players all
right
now in the current cell which is already
filled we are going to find the total
goals from each
Club earlier we saw the total assists
from each club now this will show us the
total goals from each Club if I run
it now you can
check we have Manchester City which
scored above 80 goals last season
followed by United that is close to 70
or exactly 70 goals they had scored
followed by Tottenham Hotspur we have
Liverpool ler by shaffield United and
full ham as well as bonley had close to
30 or less than 30 goals in fact safield
United scored less than 20
goals
cool next we are going to check
the most goals by
players so I'll say topor
10or
Goals to I'll say _ DF again we are
going to take the name column followed
by the
club by this time we going to consider
the goals
column also take the matches
column say
n
largest make sure there are no spelling
mistakes say n equal to
columns to
goals and let's
print players with the most number of
goals you can see
here Harry Kane played 35 matches in the
last season of EPL and scored the
maximum number of goals so he should
have won the Golden Boot as well so he
had scored 23 goals and if you see the
above table that we created he also gave
the most number of SS so he's a
brilliant player from England plays as a
striker and currently the captain of
England as well after that we had
Mohammad Salah who scored 22 goals
followed by Bruno Fernandez who scored
18 goals from 37 matches then we have
song hung men Patrick Bamford from leits
United who scored 17 goals
Etc
Co and the next cell we are going to
find out the top 10 goals per
match that is
the goals
scored in each of the M we are going to
find the
percentage I'll create a variable called
top 10 goals per
match Al to eplore
DF calculate the name
then also take the goals per match
column if you remember we had created
this goals per match column above let me
just show you in case you forgot here
you can see we had created this extra
column called goals per match this is
the last column that we have in our data
frame is basically the total number of
goals divided by the total number of
matches the player had
played if I scroll down
we are going to take the name column the
goals per
match
next we'll consider
the CH
column and then we'll also take the
goals
column dot I'll use the
N largest function and see Nal to
comma
columns equal
to per
match finally let's print the top
gos per
match here you can
see we
have Kane
scored 6 goals in a match then we have
Mohammad Salah with. 59 Joe Willock with
0 five H lingard scored nine goals in 16
matches so his goals per match stands at
.5 basically it is the total number of
of goals divided by the total number of
matches
cool in the next
cell we're going to create a pie chart
that will show us the goals with SS and
without
SS so I'll start with my pie chart as
PLT do figure we set the figure
size to foot comma
7 create a variable called SS equal to
we are going to find the total number of
ss so I'll subset my SS column and I'm
going to use the sum function over it
then I'll say data equal
to we're going to
take the total
goals
minus
SS comma and then we'll have
SS let's set the labels as well I say
labels equal
to
goals
without
SS and next
label will be gools with
SS we'll say color equal to SNS
do color
pallet see I'll take set
one and finally we are going to use the
PLT
do Pyon
function give my
data and labels equal
to
labels colors equal to the color that we
just set
above we again use the autop PCT
parameter to give the percentage
values I'll say within quotations
percentage dot 0 F percentage
percentage display I'll say PLT do
show everything is fine let me just
recheck it and we'll run
it it says Pi got an unexpected error
color this should be colors equal to
color is not defined again let's Okay
this should be PLT do show there you go
so you see we have have our pie chart
and in the pie chart you can see at
least 69% of the goals were scored with
asses and the rest of the 31% goals in
the last season of English Premier
League were scored without
assist coming to the
final plot in our live demo session on
English Premier League data analysis we
are going to see the top 10 players with
the most yellow cards so basically the
players who commit the most number of
fouls in a game are given a yellow card
or a red card so for here I'm using the
yellow cards column and I am going to
find out the first 10 players with the
most number of yellow cards received in
the last season of
EPL let's run
it and if you see we have John megin who
plays for I guess Aston Villa received
the most number of yellow cards that is
12 followed by the captain of Manchester
United this is very surprising Harry
MaGuire
got 11 yellow cards last season followed
by Connor
Gallagher and we have Douglas louiz
Kevin Phillips Mason Holgate as well in
this as well as Ruben
NIS okay so that brings us to our live
demo session on football data analysis
using the English Premier League 2020
2021 data set you understood how to load
the data set then we explored different
functions that are available in n and
pandas after that you saw how to create
P charts bar
graphs and then you also created a box
plot we saw
the total number of goals scored by each
Club the total number of assess the
players with the highest number of goals
the players with the highest number of
assess then the goals that were scored
in penalties and without
penalties all right live video session
on eppl 2020 2021 data analysis project
by simply loan I hope it was useful and
informative if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video in this
tutorial we will learn to create a
Discord board and add it to our Discord
Channel and here we will learn how to
get the following responses from the
board the responses would be text image
video document or audio and before
starting let us have a simple question
to brush up on our knowledge and it's
related to Discord and your question is
what is the minimum age to use Discord
and your options
are the first option is 18 the second
option is 13 and the third option is 15
and the fourth option you get is none of
these so please answer in the comment
section below pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section and I have an insightful for you
guys if you are focused on building
strong Foundation skills for career
growth in that case you can check out a
free course to Learn Python Basics with
a completion certificate from skillup by
simply learn you can check this course
with the link in the description box
below and now first we'll see the demo
of our Discord board and then we'll
start to create our project and for that
we will move to our Visual Studio Cod so
this is our Visual Studio code and this
is the code for our the simple Discord
board we'll also create the music
Discord board but first we'll create the
simple Discord board to just get the
responses from the board as text image
files or
video so we'll save this and run
this so it shows that we have logged in
as simply learn Bo
so we will move to Discord and I have
created the simply lar server and in
that I have the simply learn
board we will go step by step and I will
show you how to create a
server and you can see the simply
unboard it's active it's showing the
green sign or the Green
Dot and
here we'll see what were the
commands we just write
hi so we are in the general Channel and
if we write
hi we get the response from the simply
and B as hello
and if we write image we'll get the
image that is rewind. PNG and this image
is stored in the same folder as of the
project and if we write video we'll get
the python. MP4 this file is also stored
in the same folder and the audio will
get this song and this file is also
stored in the same folder and if we
write file we'll get the same file that
is python. PDF and that is stored in the
same
folder so I'll show you some
commands uh I will write
image and the board responds me with the
rewind. PNG that is stored in the
folder I will show you guys
so this is the rewind. PNG what I got
when I wrote image so moving on now
we'll start with a board and I will show
you the demo of music port before
creating
that
now the first thing we'll do is create a
new folder for our project and we'll
create a folder
and name it
as this code
board using
Python and in this folder we'll open the
command
prompt and we will open our idle that is
Visual Studio code you can use any IDE
that you have hands on we will be using
the visual studio
code and here we will create a file and
name it as
main.py and before starting the first
thing we should do is install and import
the libraries and before starting let us
have a simple discussion about what is a
Discord so Discord is a voice and text
communication platform for gamers
players streamers and developers use
Discord to discuss games answer
questions chat while they play and much
more it even has a game store complete
with critical reviews and a subscription
service it is nearly a One-Stop shop for
gaming communities I'll show you I have
downloaded the desktop version of
Discord so this is a Discord and while
there are many things you can build
using Discord apis this tutorial will
focus on a particular learning outcome
how to make a Discord board in Python
and if I tell you what is a boat so
automated programs that look and act
like users and automatically respond to
events and commands on Discord are
called board
users so this was the brief about the
discorde and what is a board now we'll
start with how to create a discorde
board so first you should have an
account on Discord for that you could
simply go to the Discord website and
register for that and you can if you
want desktop you can download the
desktop app or you can access the
Discord within the
browser now you should have an account
on
Discord and you should create a server
in that to create a server you can see
this plus sign just click on that that
is add a server and now you can see for
whom you want to create the server I
want to create a server for my
friends and that would be for me and my
friends and he's asking for the server's
name so we will write project
server and we'll click on the create
button so we have created a server and
it has channels that is General Games
music and voice channels that is lounge
and stream
room now we have created a server now we
will move to
Discord development website for that
we'll write Discord developer portal and
this is the website that is HTTP col
discord.com developers St
inro so in this
website
we will create a new application so
first we have to go to the applications
and I've created three applications and
here we will create a new application
and name it
as
project we will take all the permissions
and click on the
create and now you could see the general
information about the Discord
board so if you want to upload any icon
you can do that for your board and we
have named it as
project and we can tag it as
boort
and chat
boort and moving
on
now we'll go to the
boat okay so first we will save the
changes and now we'll go to the board
and click on ADD board and now we have
to confirm by clicking yes do
it now after the boat is
added now we'll copy the board token and
before
that we'll just give the board
permissions and before giving the board
permissions we'll go to the
authorization
to and
here we'll select inap
authorization and we'll select the scope
as B and give the permissions add ad
administrator
permissions
and here we'll save the
change and in the URL
generator we
will select the scope as board and the
board permissions we'll set it as
administrator and we'll copy this
URL and paste it
here just to store that and we'll open
that in the
browser we have to open this in the
browser and here we'll see the server we
have created the project server we'll
select that and we'll click on continue
and it has the administrator we'll
authorize it and it's asking if we are a
human or not so we'll just fill its
capture and you can see that are both is
authorized so we will see in the
Discord that project just showed up that
is the project board so it has showed up
but it's
offline so now we have to make it online
we'll do it by writing a code and before
that we have to generate the
token of a
board
so in the authorization to we have done
the things and here we have
generated the link and authorized our
board now
here we'll give the
permissions that is requires
authorization to code
Grant intent so member intent okay we
will give all the permissions as we
would be creating the music board also
so
for that we would be requiring the
administrator
permissions that is all these
permissions send messages create private
threads attach files so all
that so here we'll save the
changes and to get the token of our
Discord Bo we'll click on the reset
token and click on the the yes do it so
we'll copy this
token and paste it here so it's a token
and this was the URL to authorize a
Discord
board so we would be using this token in
a code to activate a boat and to get it
online and if you get your token
mishandled or you have given to someone
you can just reset it so so after this
project I will reset this token so you
guys can't use my
token so moving on
now we will install some libraries that
would be Discord
library and to install
that I will show you the simple
commands that is present in the the
browser you just have to write
install
Discord
python Library okay and this is the
official
website you just have to copy the
command move to your command prompt or
The Terminal of your ID and just paste
this
command and press
enter you can see that the requir is
already satisfied as I have already
installed the Discord Library so here I
don't have to install it
again and you can do it just by writing
the command in the command prompt or in
the terminal and here we are using pip
to install the
command now moving
on after installing the
libraries and authorizing our
Discord board now we'll write code to
get a board online and get some
responses from him so first we'll import
the Discord library and for that we'll
write the command import
Discord so here we have imported the
Discord and
now first we'll get our P online and for
that first we'll set the
intents that
is
Discord
dot
intents not
all and after
that we will create a variable client
and in
that we will call
discord.
client and inside we'll write command
prefix so if you want to give any
command so if it has the prefix that
will enter so a board would understand
that that would be exclamation mark and
we'll set the
intents that is
intents equal to
intents we have created a variable and
set the
intents now we will create a event that
would be client. event you could visit
the
Discord official website and see the
documentation of how to install it that
is if you want to use the PIP command
you can use that in
Linux and you could see the voice Voice
boort by NCL we will install it for our
Music board and you can see this is the
quick example to see how we can use the
Discord
Library so we have set the
intents
and now we going to make a Bo active so
you could just visit the documentation
read it once and you would understand
how this library is functioning and what
classes and functions it
possess so we'll move back to our
ideally and here we'll create the event
for that we'll write at
theate client that the variable we have
created do
event
and inside it we'll use
async and create a function function
that is
onore
ready and here we will
print that we have logged in
as if a board has logged in it should
get
printed we have logged in as the name of
the
user
or our
Port
okay and write dot
format and inside we'll pass
client now we'll create another event
that is at
theate client
do
event and
inside we will create another
function that is onore message so if we
give any message to our board he will
reply to
us so message
and
if message. author so who is writing the
message is equal
to client do
user then we'll just return and
if message.
content Dot starts with that is if the
message starts with hi or we can write
hello so a board should respond with
something so if a message starts with
high so we will
await
and message
dot
channel do send
we will send
hello and now
to make a board active the last thing we
have to do is we have to run a token run
a board with the help of token so you
know we have copied the token and that
we have copied here so I'll copy this
and paste it in client.
run so we will save
this and run
it so you could see
that it has shared logging in using
static
token and it has shared the session ID
that the board has been logged in and
what we have printed is that we have
logged in as project #
7634 so here we will move to a
Discord and here you can see that a boat
has been online after we have run the
code that is we can see the green symbol
for that and we have written the
commands if we
write hi to aort or the message which
starts with high it would respond to us
so you
could directly chat with the board here
that is just click on its symbol and you
can message at theate project at theate
project that is your board so we'll just
write hi
here and you could see that our board
responds with hello and if we go back to
a project server so this is a project
server and if we write high in any
channel that is we are writing in
general
Channel and press enter so here also our
board will respond that is
hello so now we'll add other
functionalities so that a port could
respond to us in different ways so now
we will ask our board to send an image
so the image could be sent through the
port in the form of file we need to give
the name to it and the file should be in
the same directory where our code is
could be done by running the code that I
will just show
you so
here now we'll start with
if
message do content
to starts
with image that is if we have
image oh
sorry that would be here that is own
message we are writing in the function
that is own message and if the message
do content starts with image If the
message has image in
it so what we will do
is we will write a command that is
await message dot channel in which
channel we have got the command as image
from the author we will write the or
send the file that is the board will
send the file in the same channel that
is message. channel do
send and here
we'll write the file
name and for that first we'll see which
files so I have some files that I have
used
formerly
so that I've stored it yeah new folder
so
yeah so these are the files that will
ask board to return us back that is the
image rewind. PNG python PDF and the
python mp4 file and the MP3 file
beautiful
mistakes so we
will copy all
these and paste in
our
directly in the same directory that we
are
coding that we are writing a
code
now we'll move back to our Visual Studio
code and here we'll
write the file name that
is file equal to
discod
dot
file yeah discorde dot file and now the
name of the
file that was
rewind.
PNG so we'll save
this and first run it to check if this
command is working or not so first we'll
kill our
terminal save it and run
it and we can see that it has given the
session ID and we have logged in as
project board we will move to our
Discord and here we'll write image in
the
channel and you can see that a Bo
responded with the rewind. PNG
image so our Command is working fine now
after running this code that is the Type
image in the channel now the board will
respond with the the image that we have
given in the file and we have seen that
now we'll get the video audio and a PDF
file through the board now to get this
first we must share the file name in the
file section for the file that we need
to share through the board in order to
acquire the video audio or the file now
we need to keep that file in the same
directory where our code is there as you
have seen that we have kept that in the
same
folder now
now we'll write the commands for video
audio and the PDF
file now first we'll write the command
for
video and that is
if message do
content dot start
with that is
video
wait
message.
channel do
send here we'll write the file name that
is file equal to
discode do file and inside we will pass
python. MP4
and that would be in the inverted
Comas sorry for cuffing
oh I have a
little now we have set for the video now
we'll set for the audio file and for
that we'll write the
command that is the same command and we
won't waste any time we'll just copy
it we should code as fast as we can and
if the message contains the
audio so what will pass we'll just see
what we
have the name of the AIO file that is
beautiful underscore
mistakes and that is
MP3
beautiful
underscore uh M Capal I think just check
it and that is yeah M is capit so now we
have written for the audio file now
we'll write for the simple
file that is our
PDF so if a command that is the command
we will give to our board if it contains
the name file then it will give us
python
PDF
okay and we'll check the
name okay the p is capital
for python
and after that we have client. run
that's it so we'll save this and first
we'll kill our terminal and click on the
Run
button so you can see that we have
logged in as project and now we'll move
back to our board so our board is active
and we'll start with the high
command so so it says hello and if we
write
highb then also it says hello that is if
our message contains high then the board
would respond with hello and if we ask
him the image he'll respond us with the
image and if we ask him with the
video it takes time like as the video is
a bit larger in
size
okay so it doesn't have any attribute
video that is python do MP4 we quote an
error
here start with video file python
MP4 just
check
yeah this is the same
file error should not have been upur
okay we have asked for the
video
yeah okay the is you have written start
with it starts with that's why I
responded for image but not for
video audio and the file
now we'll save this and first we'll kill
the terminal and run the code
again we can see the session ID and it
has logged in now we'll move back to our
project and now we'll ask the board for
video and we'll see what it
responds yeah you can see that it has
responded with the video you can also
play
and if we ask for
image it gives us the remind
image and if we ask for the
audio it has shared the audio that is
beautiful uncore mistakes and we ask for
the
file file
please
so I think we got any
error that is going start with
file and we have python PDF and the
error is p too large okay the request
entity is too
large so we have not subscribed with the
Nitro version so we can just send the
the 8 MB files we'll just check what is
the
size okay it's of 9 MB so it won't
share so you can place any file that is
less than 8 MB your board would respond
for
that
and with that we are done with a boat
and we are ready we with a
boat and with that we have come to the
end of this session that's a app on our
python projects for beginners I hope you
found these projects not only
informative but also enjoyable to work
on a big thank you for watching and
following along your support means the
world to us and it's what keeps this
Channel Growing if you enjoyed this
video and learned something new please
give it a thumbs up and share it with
your friends it really helps the channel
and if you have good questions or did
you create something cool from these
projects drop a comment below we love
seeing your creations and hearing your
thoughts until next time keep coding
keep creating and never stop learning
see you in the next video staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here